okay
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to three different things
first i'm going to be reacting to this
lady
called good mother i thought it was
interesting she made a video reacting to
me on
um
donovan's show and she had a lot to say
about the way i felt about a situation
and i think that i should be able to
speak for myself so i'm gonna react to
that first i also good mother if you see
this
i want to give you an open invite to my
channel um
because i think i'd like to have more
conversations with like women that are
somewhat familiar in this space
second off i'm going to be reacting to
michaela peterson on the roommates and
third if i have time you know you know
time
third i'm going to be reacting to
rollo tomasi on
michaela like what he says about
michaela because
yeah
that's what
react to some more nba young boy
my dude all of these video people
copyright strike me and i make no money
like none i i cannot react to copyright
live
um because all of l i don't want to say
that they're kind of being [ __ ]
about it but all these people like
it's like i'm an up-and-coming youtuber
i'm just trying to
anyways it's just irritating but hold on
let me
let me get here so i'm in
otherwise i would 100 like only do music
reactions but i just even when i was
getting a lot of subscribers and [ __ ] i
was making no money and it was just way
too frustrating
like way too frustrating
um
okay so
this one okay
this
good mother
she said
this was pretty annoying to watch this
was me
i watched a different i don't know if
this is a clip from her live
or whatever
it is
i wish my audience enjoyed 2x as much as
i do it saves you so much time
[ __ ] about you and i want black women to
stop [ __ ] posting tell her nicky
y'all let him know something nickies
let them know something
just to focus on themselves be
successful and then you go out there and
you decide the trajectory of your life
oh boy uh-oh
i do i do agree with her
okay
about like let's stop talking about who
doesn't want us i agree with that like i
don't care who doesn't want to date me
ah no hold on pearl i agree listen
you're 100 right
right the reason why you don't care who
doesn't want to date you
is because you're a white girl
that's why
black women are at the bottom of the
sexual food chain and what this means
very clearly is most men don't prefer
black women so the reason why black
women [ __ ] and moan about the top black
men not wanting them is because we are
we are their only option are there black
women who can and do date outside their
race absolutely but 99.9 of them cannot
this is why black women specifically
[ __ ] and moan about the kinds of black
men who won't date them that's why
well i mean but i've had like guys say
they prefer like tan girls with like
dark hair
and like that are shorter i know but i'm
like
i'm saying like i don't it didn't bother
me
of course not because or even even like
i've had like guys that i was interested
in say they only date black girls like
and i'm like
okay wait a minute i got it uh pearl
yeah is she not at her commentary on
this
been to you ever been to san francisco
no oh
um
okay this was on the stream hold on
i thought
let's go back to
sorry guys i know i just saw one that
she was like because i got a
notification
[Music]
swore swore i did
um
working in the opposite direction that
me and many many many many [ __ ] other
people are working in so
i've tried to
i've tried to uh
let him know on various occasions maybe
give him some ideas
us or he just doesn't remember
which if he just doesn't remember
that leads to a bigger [ __ ] problem
so
yeah this interaction this is it this is
so
when he announced that he was taking his
channel and trying to do some [ __ ] in a
different direction and he was gonna try
to do what fresh and fit and kevin
samuels are doing
which i mean kevin samuels kind of has
his own thing going on
um
i mean there's structure to it
he he tries to talk to women he
shows how
hard it is to get women to even [ __ ]
speak the truth
he tries to listen to them he also tries
to relate information to them
[Music]
i mean but he's critical of men and
women
so
i mean kevin samuels is doing a [ __ ]
badass job and he's having a lot of
these really really important hard
conversations with a lot of people and
spreading a message which is such a good
thing
fresh and fit
i also support fresh and fit i mean yeah
they do a lot of that
whatever pill stuff but they're
constantly hammering on feminism and
trying to
you know plant some seeds into these
stupid [ __ ] that they have up on
their panel and i do enjoy a lot of
their discussions that they have without
the women you know
and then they did do two
pretty serious uh pretty i thought
courageous [ __ ]
uh podcasts or shows
sorry i'm trying to skip to where the
video starts okay why is she sitting
there for one
um oh wait okay maybe i should what she
represents for two okay right
she is my number one
target because
she has the biggest cult of man-hating
feminists
okay so this lady
because usually when people don't like
donovan it's like
she is all for the divesting she is all
for oh she's talking about that cynthia
chick aborting
male babies
she is all for
um
using white men
to
you know throw in the face of black men
that you know white men are better
and white men
said this about you and that about you
oh my gosh i just don't care at all i
think race is so unimportant
like i know people will say like because
i use whitest girl on earth like
i do that for clickbait guys and to be
like funny but i don't actually
like race just does not matter
but the thing with cynthia g and i don't
know if it's true for donovan sharp
cynthia g claims to have psychology
credentials like
like an actual [ __ ] degree in this
like this is a woman that's supposed to
be responsible for the mental health of
our society and she's literally using
those tools to abuse men
create more of a divide
and and it's disgusting so she literally
has almost a hundred thousands oh my god
get to it
that she gaslights continuously she'll
have a conversation with the white man
and then do a breakdown
and try to explain what he meant when he
said things and then she twists the
message she twists it to [ __ ] poke
and attack the black man with it so it
in turn pisses black men off and they
think it's because the white man said it
when in fact it's because she [ __ ]
twisted it for her own
i saw a lot of that in in this and i i
mean
i don't know
my internet go
usually stay away from criticizing the
men because i believe that the men can
sort the [ __ ] men out
they can but
this woman i don't think is qualified to
[ __ ] even understand
why she's sitting there for one okay
ma'am
respectfully i'm gonna say this in the
most respectful way possible i'm gonna
let me just see when
when you started your channel
um
good mother also guys consider donating
to the stream
okay i am all donations are going
towards
equipment for my show that's going to be
called the
the pre-game and the reason it's called
the pre-game is because i think that the
best conversations happen at the
pre-game and not the party i think the
pre-game is better than the party so
i'm going to have my hot friends
come on
and
we are going to talk about different
dating dynamics and topics so if you
guys have watched
more than two of my lives consider
donating your girl is struggling out
here okay ma'am respectfully i've been
on this platform longer than you have
like i have
like five times the amount of videos you
have
on this stuff okay
um oh wait hold up
like wait i'm not qualified get out
okay
um
what she represents for two
and there's a lot of information that
he's trying to feed her that's poor [ __ ]
and it will [ __ ] ruin her life so she
needs to get the [ __ ] out of there it's
gonna ruin my oh my gosh there's nothing
no one can say to me that is going to
ruin my life
i'm sorry i just it is nothing is that
deep
so i'm going to break down some stuff
and i want to point out some things
because can you guys hear me okay on the
mic i'm a little further from my mic
than normal let me know in the comments
if you can hear me this is
this also is a really good example of
what uh
me and sun kissed and delisha had a
conversation about the kind of people
that
like poke and poke and poke and poke at
people like i don't see her as a crazy
[ __ ] at all
thank you
thank you
i can see if she sticks in this
environment how it could [ __ ] drive
her crazy
so that's not a good thing
all right
i mean it is what it is man listen i was
a fat ass i was unmotivated
like i said i want to [ __ ] me either um
i thought stephanie all the time but
that was that was another story
um
king life says vicky's husband is a
triple x offender the king's two dollar
says oh her husband went to jail for
epar and deleting people oh okay notice
e par
uh spell it backwards
oh
okay so for one
that's rape spelled backwards it's rape
people say great people say all sorts of
[ __ ]
um
because for some weird reason the men
aren't allowed to say rape they can get
cancelled they can get their channels
like flagged or removed for saying rape
even though the feminists have the
[ __ ] monopoly
on claiming i don't know anything about
that hold on guys
i forgot my starbucks cup in the other
room i don't want it to get cold
oh hold on
oh my gosh
okay i'm back
sorry
great all the [ __ ] time they can say
it all the time
so
these men are afraid to use [ __ ]
words
that is an example of that
right i don't like using certain words
like instead of uh talking about um
ending pregnancy before it goes to term
abortion
i call it a noit robot because
robot is abortion spelled backwards
oh yeah there's certain things instead
of saying dv i say domestic duracell
what's duracell it's a battery
domestic violence
wow yeah
well and again
necessity is the mother of invention um
guys like myself i have to be very
careful about the things that i say
because you know yeah because of the uh
the youtube thoughts so nicki minaj got
all successful but she's married to it
and i don't know if youtube bots is code
word for crazy [ __ ] emotional
[ __ ] that get offended that use the
report button because that's what kills
these channels it's not an hour i'm a
big fan of letting crazy people talk
like okay i don't think donovan's crazy
okay but if i did i would not report his
channel
i don't i don't think you stop crazy
people from talking you let them talk
and let the people decide if they're
crazy
like
most people have some form of common
sense
and you can you can kind of tell when
people are nuts
i i feel pretty confident
that i've already disproven that i have
three channels
and if it was an algorithm
some of these streams get tagged or
flagged on one channel and not the other
two
it does not make sense to me that it's
an algorithm it's actual human people
that report [ __ ]
and then whoever is in charge of
deciding
whether or not
it
goes against some kind of policy
it's like those two people make the
decision so
i know there's a lot of women a lot of
feminists that work for these tech
companies
so
crazy [ __ ]
canceled okay i'm waiting for the dating
dynamics stuff because
my my channel isn't really about
politics to be honest
with sex offender who also has ended the
lives of others
so do you see what the message is here
yeah nicki minaj is married to a sex
offender who has ended people
do you think his value is high
no there you go there you go listen
shout out to her i'm glad she's living
the life but this is this is what it is
so so for all you [ __ ] that's the one
that i want to take that what the [ __ ]
out at eat a dick go away
and i want black women to stop [ __ ]
posting tell her thank you
let him know something mickey
just to focus on themselves be
successful and then you go out there and
you decide the trajectory of your life
oh boy oh okay i do i do agree with her
okay
about like let's stop talking about who
doesn't want us i agree with that like i
don't care who doesn't want to date me
ah no no hold on pearl i agree listen
you're 100 right yeah right the reason
why you don't care who doesn't want to
date you
is because you're a white girl
see that's pushing that [ __ ]
narrative right there
he's saying because she doesn't care
it's because she's white
that's problematic
that's why
black women are at the bottom of the
sexual food chain and what this means
very clearly is most men don't prefer
black women so the reason why black
women [ __ ] and moan about the top black
men not wanting them is because we are
we are their only option are there black
women who can and do date outside their
race absolutely but 99.9 of them cannot
this is why black women specifically
[ __ ] and moan about the kinds of black
men who won't date them that's one well
also the an element to that is a lot of
um
resentful black men will take white
women
and like
rub it in the face of black women i mean
not all black men do that of course but
that's an element that's a piece to this
equation
oh i mean but i've had like guys say
they prefer like tan girls with like
dark hair
and like that are shorter i know that
i'm like
i'm saying like i don't it's a bother
okay the guy i liked um the guy i i i
was dated in college
he left me for a black girl i'm just
saying you don't
we don't always win they always say like
we always win i'm like
do we
stop because or even even like i've had
like guys that i was interested in say
they only date black girls like and i'm
like
okay wait a minute
but i've also i've also i'm not gonna
like deny that i've also heard guys say
they only date white girls that are
black like i've heard it both ways
but at the end of the day comparison is
the thief of joy
and if you spend your time like focusing
on [ __ ] you can't change you cannot
change
who wants to date your race and who
doesn't want to date your race like
you you can't
you can't change that so
i don't know
that's why it's just not really worth
focusing on in my opinion because you
can't change it just focus on the people
that want to date you and are interested
in you and if nobody's interested in you
try to lose weight and i guarantee
people will be but uh you ever been to
san francisco
see he changes the subject because she
had something that contradicted his
claim
and another you know thing
he's changing the subject
now you ever been to new york
yes have you taken a walk on the dark
side
[Music]
do you know that do you know what the
theme is i don't get it i don't get it
you want to listen yeah i'll walk on the
dark side
i said all that to say that you you are
attracted to black men that's yeah
that's what i was getting at yes i was i
was just gonna have some fun with you
but the reason why the reason why you're
not tripping when black men tell you
well i only date black women that's
because you can date any race of man you
want black women cannot you say that's
funny do you know how that catcher dicks
what he told me when i was dating my
black boyfriend
he said i would be tainted forever and
i'm like
would i
okay but
trust me i
it would not be hard to get a a white
boyfriend if i wanted one
not that i don't want any boyfriend
right now don't misconstrue that none
none
yeah well i
i think that most
see
she's she's trying to
formulate a thought
that she can express
and he's [ __ ] like interrupting her
because
like this is some like
indoctrination happening right now i
mean he keeps [ __ ] pushing on this
topic
and she's trying to
like he's trying to tell her
how she feels about [ __ ] man
ma'am not man ma'am respectfully there's
nothing this man could say to me
to change my preference
there's nothing there's nothing he could
say to me to change who i find
attractive and like half the reason i
think i i've dated black guys is because
i'm a really high energy person and
black guys just like tend to be more
high energy
and they're like
like i don't want to say all because
clearly not all but like
a good amount of them are funny like i
like funny guys or the guys that just
say nothing
either or that's my type
because i i have a pretty big like
vibrant personality so either like the
guy that lets me talk or is like funny
with me so we can like
roast each other a little bit
which women complain about
men doing
but i think they complain about it
because there are some men that have
their [ __ ] perceptions completely
[ __ ] wrong
and they don't have any idea what
they're talking about i actually
experienced that um for many many months
talking to
a couple red pill guys
that's cap you don't want a boyfriend
now but if the right guy came along
you're gonna give him a shot
i think if the right guy came along
right now i would ruin it because
i told you i just got out of a
relationship guys i'm trying to like
like i don't know just
take a step back before i get into
something because that'll ruin a
relationship not being over the last one
so
trying to tell me
how i think how i feel what i believe
based on this uh
ideology this doctrine
well i don't think it's doctrine i think
it's data and i'm not i'm not saying
this this isn't a fun reality right
again this isn't fun but black women are
the least
swiped on in dating apps same with i
think indian men
um but you don't know why and you don't
know what the reason is for that
and it could be because statistically
black women are overweight more than
white women right like i don't think
it's their race
um
yeah so
it's just my two cents it's not it's not
a fun reality but that's why donovan
thinks like that but that's not the
reality i live in right
because i i
most of the black girls i know are are
athletes so they're they're usually in
pretty good shape
[ __ ] teach
like
they teach these men how to read women
and
i want to say a good [ __ ] 85 of the
time they're wrong
so a lot of these guys are walking
around here with a lot of wrong [ __ ]
information
so i don't trust a man to [ __ ] relay
that kind of [ __ ] information
i mean
maybe
teaching
women how men think maybe and feel about
certain situations as men
but a man has no [ __ ] idea
when it comes to the complexity of women
unless they are very very
like experts in all those fields and
have a network of people that they you
know confirm [ __ ] with which this guy
doesn't like he he he's not a fan of
women
really he doesn't really listen to
women's input no we have a whole panel
ma'am did you do your research
we have a whole panel on his show tune
it on sunday so look here's the thing
about donovan i don't agree with
everything he says
like i think tla roasted the hell out of
him and i thought it was funny i'm not
gonna lie i'm sorry donovan
i'm sorry he thinks i'm tainted like
there's [ __ ] there's [ __ ] we
disagree on okay
but at the end of the day i don't care
like we worry so much about what other
people think
i don't care if he thinks i'm tainted i
don't care if he has opinions i disagree
with if we have a working relationship
and he's helping me with my channel he
and he's giving me an opportunity to
speak on his platform like what does it
matter what he thinks and even if he
thinks something different than me who
cares because we can talk about it and
have disagreements and have debates
like
we worry so much about what other people
think
and i like you have to think about it
every day you talk to a million people
in your day-to-day life you have no idea
what they think about a million topics
you're never really gonna know unless
you know
they start telling all their opinions on
youtube that's what i do
so
this is all his idea
and she's pushing she's trying to push
back on it and he's [ __ ] interrupting
her which
it gets worse
i'm not i like white guys i don't i
don't listen i know you do i know i'm
what you guys have to understand is that
pearl is you are six feet tall i think a
lot of guys don't realize that there you
go
yeah
um
i forgot what i was gonna say
if it comes if it comes back no we were
talking about the fact that you've had
men tell you oh
oh no no because you said okay i think
most black girls
like i've got a lot of black girls that
definitely could date white guys okay i
think if they're like fit feminine
friendly like they're you're not gonna
have a problem to be honest of any race
i agree totally pearl's like dude
pearl's trying to hide her face because
she doesn't want people to it is what it
is
okay someone said in the comments black
women are the least popular on dating
apps because of their attitudes and
asian because of stereotypes peanut oh
can i say that i'm live
okay sorry um size is one of them
oh i'm sure stereotypes play into it
sure
yeah i mean that's part of it
but
to be honest i think most men will put
up with a lot of attitude if
she's attractive enough i'm
just just telling you what i've seen
sorry
counseling therapy
i recommend therapy often oh god
because we got a lot of stuff
individually we want to deal with it
there we go and managing relationships
are not for everybody and i'm just
trying to ultimately ask you
what do you want what do you want
and what are you prepared to do to get
what you want and are you willing to pay
that cost it's really the conversation
but always just kind of whittled down so
let me ask you this pearl
um because i don't think i've ever had a
i don't think i've ever had a
conversation with you about this what's
your ideal guy what kind of what kind of
man are you looking for because i
remember one time i think was our last
episode you're like wait a minute at a
certain age i'm going to come into some
money and so
a man with a lot of resources is
attractive but that's not the most
important thing so
let's just assume all things considered
what kind of man is going to be able to
take hannah pearl davis off the market
fun fact my first name's hannah yup a
lot of you didn't know
are you talking about like if i got like
perfect like every single thing i wanted
because a lot of times they'll say women
have high standards and we do like if i
had to list every single thing i wanted
yeah
for sure
but you know i'm i'm not perfect i don't
expect him to be perfect so
yeah okay that's right
like well tell me what your references
are
uh oh yeah your attraction form that i
mean there's attraction for this
attraction floor okay okay that's fine
because
uh you know what i forgot to add to this
no kids
no kids
i want them to be the same politics and
religion
oh my god okay
i'll stop i promise go ahead go ahead
she just said i'll hit you if i was
there so she's getting frustrated and
irritated because he's [ __ ] playing
like he keeps asking her questions and
as soon as she goes to answer like he
[ __ ] interrupts her with a whole
bunch of [ __ ] like that is a serious
sign of disrespect
and it's [ __ ] annoying
i wasn't
i really wasn't annoyed like i knew he
was just kidding
to be honest i could i could take a joke
i could take a joke ma'am like if you
really
just want to tell her her opinions on
everything why even [ __ ] ask her
like asking is even worse
because it gives the person the
perception that you actually give a [ __ ]
what they think i wasn't offended i'm
just gonna let you guys know
i'm gonna let you guys know i was not
offended
i'm i can take a joke i'm a jokester
i could do a little banter it's cool
like that's that's how i
like i'm not above being made fun of
like
and then they go to start telling you
and then you [ __ ] cut them off so
that's that's a kind of uh mental
manipulation that
manipulation um
makes people crazy
um
[Music]
that makes people violent
i mean she was honest she was like if i
was there i would [ __ ] hit you like
i don't know um okay i want him to be
taller than me of course it actually
makes dating a lot harder because it
does ideally like 62 and higher but 511
is good like okay and pearl i want you
to understand a lot of people say oh my
god pearl's just like the typical no
pearl is six feet tall pearl hey listen
i'm sure you could date shorter guys but
it just doesn't it's you're just not
going to be that's so true
ah i wish i'm sorry short guys i'm not
there you
i don't want to say i'm never attracted
to short guys but it's it's not as
common for me it's not it doesn't it
doesn't but if they're my highlight i'm
good with that um
cause i'm five eleven and a half if
we're going to be excited
i got you six feet also
guys send a donation to the chat if
you've been watching for more than like
five minutes help a girl out i'm trying
to save for four more mics i have four
mics
that i'm gonna be doing a live show on
it's gonna be called the pregame all my
friends are gonna come over we're gonna
party
and talk about different relationship
topics why because the pre-game i think
is better than the party you have better
conversations at the pre-game than the
party
i have four mics kind of five kind one's
like kind of shitty but maybe five i
would like to get to eight mics and
another sound board i need to raise
about a thousand dollars i'm at about
like 125 of that a thousand
so each and every donation even if it's
just two dollars like seriously helps
the channel
oh
[Music]
bro any athlete we all round up i used
to say six one
so like 5 11 5 10 and a half that's fine
um
um
so taller than me ideally same politics
same religion
or i don't care if he's like super
religious i just it's really i went to
catholic school and i'd like kids to go
to catholic school okay so um
he just has to be like cool with that
and be like dragging them to church on
sundays okay
um
and then
i work at i always say it's not about
the job it's about his work ethic i want
a guy that like is passionate i always
say i would marry a coach if he was
passionate about it i do not care
hold on stop the stream 20 super chat
thank you so much
thank you sir now we're at like 140 out
of the thousand dollar goal i have
i appreciate you so much
thank you thank you thank you i will
read your comments
what he's passionate about i think you
can make money doing a lot of things but
i need like
work ethic i work very hard at the
things i do and i just i want someone
that's like
okay hold on i'm gonna pause here
trey
that's the same
eddie
how do you know she's turned on oh my
god every time i get along with a guy i
swear to god they always make it out to
be like something it's not every time
anytime you just like get along with
somebody i swear
actually
i'll invite you up after this is over
because
i get you said you're red pilled or
whatever but
a lot of that [ __ ] is [ __ ]
a lot of the stuff
that um
that doctrine teaches isn't even true so
working towards something and driven
okay um
and like in shape like i'm not in shape
but like working out you know has some
sort of like workout yeah not oh
not a fat ass
yeah but like he doesn't have to be like
you know like perfect you know but yeah
actually that's like my floor
but that's
that's like i'd say my floor does that
make sense yeah that makes perfect sense
is that delusional no that's i mean
well well it depends the reason i ask
that is that kevin must ask nikki hey
are you willing to work for that so now
let me ask you this question
that guy
i don't want to say your ideal guy but
the guy at your attraction for
at this point in time do you think guys
at your attraction before want women
like you yes or no
he was not expecting my answer i swear
to god he wasn't
no
like no probably not
um because i just got out of a
relationship so and i have a youtube
channel like what guy wants to be the
girl with the youtube channel i think i
should wait a little bit okay all right
yeah
you just kept it all the way real uh
king live two dollars says pearl saved
the black uh the berry the sweeter the
juice oh please no i'm not gonna say
that
there we go
hold on let's get rachel let's get
rachel i call brother myron the [ __ ]
from sudan
hold on hold on he said i'm loving the
knife writer sound effect yes sir
you know it okay
oh boy yeah that that's gonna be uh
that's gonna be um that that's gonna be
a hit um blind blamer 2009 says we need
to get her an nba player yeah uh tech uh
technological chaos
check out my last video it's me shooting
my shot at 50 nba players wanna know how
many responded repeat my last video
yeah
like you are you are really really
really tall i'm actually looking forward
to meeting you in person because i think
because i'd be like wow because i've
never there was one model that i hired
uh it's funny all my friends are taller
than me like or my height like my friend
gabby that's always on my channel is
like six three i'm six foot well five
eleven and a half she was actually six
feet tall i looked i mean i was like wow
you're really tall how tall are you six
feet awesome okay i'm short for my
position actually
like it's the girls tend to be like six
two i'm sure because i'm trying to go
pro next year and that's like a problem
cause i'm too short
wait wait hold on hold on hold on
so you're trying to go pro and one of
the challenges is that you're too short
yes i'm too short for my position
very good very good
oh the guy texted me back
all right what happened i said hey i'm
in chicago are you busy tonight cause i
was trying to like respond first yes but
i have an 8 a.m flight tomorrow so i'm
going to be early what do you want me to
say oh
say uh say i'm horny let's get drinks
tonight
this is going to be funny and okay i
think this lady thought this was like
dating advice no i was trying to prove a
point that i have guy friends that like
wouldn't want to sleep with me
and don't look at me like that
you know girl who's six three where are
they finding you all
volleyball
i know there's like
two or three girls on my team like six
two to six three ish
in the end you can learn short on a
volleyball team is like five five like
that's
short i'm off the hook be like listen
i'm gonna tell them later but yes of
course
all right horny let's get drinks tonight
go ahead hit send
it do it oh she did
now this is funny the now this is one of
the guys and you were like
i don't think he's going to believe me
yes your smile your smile betrays your
words young person no it doesn't i just
this is embarrassing yeah because i knew
i was like oh i'm about to get rejected
hard it's gonna be embarrassing
but it's okay i was trying to prove a
point
wait is he now the guy is he a white guy
or is he
his wife okay uh he
he might actually turn you down because
if he was a dude if he was a [ __ ] he'd
be like uh-huh let's do it let's do it
let's continue
but
see he's so [ __ ] coursing her into
becoming a [ __ ] night right ma'am
nobody can coerce me into becoming a
night rider
like nobody
i could attracted you i'm attracted to
oh my gosh
like
i guarantee there's nobody on the planet
that could make me attracted to short
guys i'm sorry short guys
i'm sorry
okay she has already made it perfectly
[ __ ] clear within what the past i
don't know
not even 10 minutes
that she doesn't [ __ ] discriminate
and and he's discouraging her and
putting i mean that that little that
little nugget right there plants a
little seed of [ __ ] doubt within her
so she's gonna be probably a little more
[ __ ] self-conscious now about this no
you'd be shocked what i'm not
self-conscious about you would be
surprised like that's
taking [ __ ] dating advice for from
any of these guys it wasn't dating
advice i was trying to prove a point is
so [ __ ] toxic
at the end of the day
what we are seeing is
you know especially if you're under 30.
it's it's harder for guys to pay under
30 than it was from 50 years ago of
course because you can't take care of a
family
on a high school or just coming out so
then
um
and i reckon i just had men's and i
recommend i told guys look why are you
130
record not work on getting yourself
together
because like it or not
you're really not in a position like
like you should be to be able to work
with me do anything like that
let me ask you this
i tell guys
in my community and my groups
before you even think about having a
long-term relationship of consequence
with a woman
i implemented the 35 and 35 rule you
must be at least 35 years old and have
smashed at least 35 women what are your
thoughts
oh god i would not recommend that of
course not you're a woman
um
[Music]
i don't know i think there's like a
certain level of like
like i think when people get married and
meet young like one of the reasons why
parents marriage is so good
um is because they really didn't
experience a lot of like worldly things
before they met that's the only time and
i think that's the only time it works
yeah and so um like they both
see
see he kind of agreed with me
um
i don't agree with kevin here waiting
until 30 is a bad idea you'll be mildly
more wealthy but with zero relationship
experience
i don't how do i put it
i think things happen on different
timelines for different people but i
don't know there's something adorable
when people meet in high school and both
just have like very pure souls
like
the dating game isn't like fun i don't
think anyways
only like slept with each other yeah i
think that's like and like that that
like remember i think men are
biologically dispositioned to want to
sleep with everything and women are
biologically dispositioned to be
hypergamous
right but here's the problem
like your habits become who you are so
if you're in the habit of like sleeping
with a bunch of random girls all through
your 20s what are the odds you're going
to be faithful
to your wife when you're in your 30s if
that's what you want but you know then
again some guys
you know just cheat forever i guess kind
of kept the level of life that makes
all the difference that makes all the
difference in their relationship that
like otherwise yeah does that make sense
that makes perfect sense
if you are now
i also think god rewards like good
behavior to be honest i'm
i'm not like a crazy religious person
like um i'd consider myself a christian
and you know i go to church i used to go
to bible study like twice a week for
like two years oh my gosh that was crazy
but
i don't know i just i i think if you do
the right things like god tends to
reward you
my mother was the virgin bride but she
still ended up being a [ __ ] she was my
dad's first and only
and i'm fairly certain my mother is the
only woman but i'm saying get your city
boy [ __ ] out the way before you put a
ring on it i'm like
kevin's never been
married long term
respectfully like what experience does
he have
and if that's effective
anyway that has ever smashed i'm just
saying
so it doesn't always work that way it
always depends upon influence but yes
again your parents are
man
you really i mean where did you grow up
pleasantville usa like
uh my mom was from
my mom is from the middle of nowhere
like a small town like a place called
potosi in wisconsin oh boy um her
graduating high school class had maybe
like 15 people wow my dad grew up also
in northern wisconsin and the south side
of chicago they were like it was kind of
weird y'all 24 are you in here someone
send a donation help a girl out help a
girl out
come on
i i work very hard you guys know i work
extremely hard on this channel i put out
so much content i've over a thousand
videos on here
and
my goal is i want to put on a really
entertaining show for you but i can't do
that unless i have money for equipment
and i guarantee this show is going to be
like nothing you have ever seen in the
manosphere there is nothing female-led
there is nothing
that
there's nothing in the manual manosphere
right now that has like more normal
women if that makes sense
and
in my opinion shows an accurate
depiction of the dating market so
consider sending your girl a donation it
all
goes towards
my equipment
um okay if you're going to troll in my
comments you will get blocked you know
who you are you will get blocked
they would like move every couple years
like back and forth so the south side of
chicago that was when the south side of
chicago used to be a good neighborhood
that wasn't
she was pretty poor he wasn't sure
her dad grew up in the hood
and in the farm like it was like half
his childhood was in the hood and half
was like on a farm
that makes a lot of sense we understand
you know why you uh you know
why your persuasion you know persuasion
towards the brothers
the i don't know my dad's not my dad's
like the whitest like man how does your
dad feel how does that feel about your
boyfriend
um
well
um i don't think he likes him i don't
think he thought we were good together
my ex-boyfriend okay um but thank you
for the super chat i knew someone would
come through okay we are at 1
45
of the 1 000 goal i know it's a lot
people i know
i know but i i promise you
that
this is going to be a great show i
promise i work very hard there's no one
else that could do this show better than
i can i guarantee it but he liked kevin
samuels he probably could like him
like even now like if i asked my dad to
like help him with stuff he still would
but well that's good like just us
together i don't think
he liked
my high school my high school sweetheart
uh her father um
did not like our relationship
obviously if i were to meet him today
if i were to his name is actually ed if
i were to meet him today i'd be like you
know what ed
i understand i understand devin tells me
all the time oh my father would my
father is going to love you and her dad
does love me
but if devin were
18 instead of now 45 that would
definitely have a problem and she
admitted as
much
let's continue
yeah i don't i don't think it was more
like his race though to be honest i
think it was more it wasn't he didn't
like
us together he didn't like the way i
acted when we were together it had
nothing to do with the fact that he was
black
it's like
we weren't like good yeah i don't know i
understand yeah we've had we've had
conversations
team peterson says pearl took the first
class ticket from san francisco to new
york oh boy
i don't get it
oh boy s f n y
i do not understand these references but
i'll take your word bro i did it i was
like what what is san francisco and new
york i thought those were cities
i thought those were cities
what do they have to do with anything
[Music]
i'll tell you what
it means she [ __ ] [ __ ] y'all sfn why
she [ __ ] it because i'm trying to tell
y'all i'm trying to tell you
so when i ask you pearl have you ever
been to san francisco everybody kind of
laughs oh my gosh
i don't know why i don't discriminate
i don't discriminate
i just i don't think race matters like
at all i do not care
oh okay
yeah pearl's expense
like but this lady she keeps trying to
make it seem like i was offended i
wasn't i could take a joke i can i'm a
jokester okay i can
i can't look it if you're above being
made fun of then you should get the hell
off the internet
because that is what you're subjecting
yourselves to okay i was not offended
they're literally
they're trying to put her in a box who
would win in a fight donovan sharp or
coach greg adams
uh i i've reacted to fights live and i
always guess wrong
so i don't know but i would
how tall is coach greg adams i don't
know i don't know
i mean this is this is a girl that
came from a good family
has values has [ __ ] gold i mean just
all the stuff that she said so far she
wants kids all the things and and the
guys are trying to uh
you know tempt her
into the dark side or i can't i can't be
tempted
there is nothing donovan could say to me
okay that would make me attracted or not
attracted to somebody
like i i'm sorry
oh my god [ __ ] what
into becoming a night rider we're trying
to claim that she also anyone that's
just coming in the chat i'm doing
michaela peterson after
this is like my starting you know thing
but then i'm i'm doing mikayla peterson
after that it's something she's [ __ ]
not and they're using language that she
doesn't even [ __ ] understand
so
this is a really weird [ __ ] situation
i'm going to go ahead
and poke women over here
that's not what's going on right now
this year we're going past the sound we
still laugh we still we still do all
that stuff we're talking about
self-awareness
um
and and moving the needle man i think i
hear my dog snoring in the background in
this
my fault my fault
talking with uh
a famous sexologist a woman is feminist
to talk about things that i may not that
people on my side may not understand to
further open the conversation right
because that's what we have
funny how pearl doesn't get offended but
she has a noticeable reaction to
everything that gets said about her i do
reactions
guys you have to understand people like
conflict in the chat
nothing online is that serious i swear
to god
it's like people like the reactions or
maybe they don't but you're in my chat
so you obviously like it a little bit
okay kevin so where's your feet
no we got it we
he responded
no
i told you he just said no i i knew this
guy would never sleep with me
respectfully like
i it just has never been like that
and i proved i proved my point i didn't
fake it either like i did not tell him i
was gonna do it
i told him after but like i did not tell
him yeah look it okay all right okay all
right oh no he's typing more uh-oh oh
to be continued to be continued please
don't text me that
oh god i'm in trouble
just tell him it was a joke
she literally texted him what he [ __ ]
told her and in
the dudes like
hmm
a man
can can can um
have sex three times a night fist for
the rest of his life
well how many times
they gonna be able to do it this is how
much it's working
there you go
see if a man is [ __ ] a man who's
[ __ ] all the time a man who's [ __ ]
all the time um doesn't have time
a man who's working all the time didn't
have time for all this [ __ ] hurricane
that's why i say it's different
as pearl tries to sell the friendship
that's okay listen do what you gotta do
it's all good
[Music]
stuff um
so uh so far uh give me your give me
your closing give me your give me your
closing thoughts on thank you so much
for the 10 donation okay
150 dollars we're at out of the thousand
dollar goal remember what is this gonna
buy a new sound board
three to four mics depending on the
conversion rate i'm not i'm not sure
exactly what it's going to be but
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you i appreciate each
and every one of you so much i know when
you're watching you don't have to donate
you don't have to do anything so when
you guys donate if real makes my day
like the support i get from you guys
crazy and i swear to god this is going
to be the best show
it is going to be a great show this uh
conversation between minaj and samuels
i thought it was great i like actually
really enjoyed them together yeah to be
honest um
i think it's really important that like
we still have conversations with people
we disagree with yeah and even if
they're different and this is this is
what look it i don't agree with
everything donovan says
like
the man called me tainted the first time
he talked to me
but i don't
who cares like i just
it doesn't really matter what people
think of you
it matters how they treat you and he is
so helpful with my youtube channel
who cares like literally who cares i
like values from them because i think it
brings like a level of understanding to
both sides also he was wrong because all
the examples of the girls he used that
were tainted all dated or married or had
a baby with white guys after so is he i
love being right so i really enjoyed it
i thought it was great
yeah i thought i thought this was a good
conversation
i mean i've only watched as much i've
only watched the first 12 minutes um
i mean i've watched as much as we just
did here
um but um i think kevin uh he's doing
the right thing man he's um he's he's
doing the smart thing and he is
he recognizes that
as far as men centric content like this
we need to involve with it this is why
i'm partnering up with you and ally and
and tallulah
because it's time to bring women donovan
is a behind the scenes mentor yeah oh my
god donovan is so helpful
is so helpful i'm like look
you can call me tainted any day of the
week if you help me that much
i'm sorry
i said it you could say women are ho you
could say whatever the hell you want i
do not care like because that's what's
important what's important is how people
treat you
it is not important what their opinions
are on the random topics we discuss in
the manosphere
you know
been into the conversation that's the
only way we're not only this is not only
is this the best way to expand our
brands and our region our influence this
is how we can help more people i've done
and
i've done all i can to improve the lives
of men and i'm never going to stop doing
that i'm a men first men central first
but
there are a lot of women out here who
are afraid to sort of speak up in these
communities and when they see women like
you on you know on on our on our female
uh on our female panel and in these solo
shows i think this gives them a little
bit more um
uh makes them a little braver so to
speak what do you think
yeah i think so too i think um
you're gonna be honest
when
this was happening i was texting my
friend i was very embarrassed i was only
half listening
like i think a lot of times women aren't
even really aware of what they're doing
wrong because there's no men that tell
them right
so i think it's helpful to us because it
also gives us like a cheat code a little
bit when we kind of understand that a
little better a little bit better and
like know what they want does that make
sense yeah it makes perfect sense um
yeah
that makes perfect sense a street
fighter 88 wants to know this pearl wear
who bearings
okay i am so tired of you guys what is
your obsession with hoop earrings they
go in and they go out they are a trend
they're a trend now i'm lazy okay as you
guys know i don't put a lot of effort
into my appearance
to a fault it's not a good thing
but
like
that's one of the trends like i don't
think it's as in right now but like two
three years ago every [ __ ] was wearing
hoop earrings
i don't wear any earrings actually
okay all right very good uh have you
ever smoked uh newport cigarettes
the same [ __ ] yeah the hoop earrings um
actually rectal mike explained to us
that that was
uh
i guess a sexual fetish
hoop earrings big enough to like bend
the chicks [ __ ] legs behind their
ears and if they can like go in the hoop
earring like that's a good thing i don't
know
i mean these are all sexual
inside [ __ ] jokes in this community
that i mean
she hasn't said anything sexual once she
hasn't he keeps saying sexual [ __ ] she
keeps saying actually real [ __ ] so
i mean i don't know why she would ask
him his [ __ ] opinion on what how she
should respond
to a guy i mean i i do understand
he comes off as some kind of it wasn't
an opinion it was like i was trying to
prove a point that not every guy i'm
friends with wants to sleep with me and
i proved my point because i
texted him and he said no
i can help her
but
like
his response
and she literally texted the dude that
and he didn't [ __ ] like it
because
she came off as [ __ ] [ __ ]
because guess what that's what these
puas want
more and more and more sweat no i think
he just is faithful and he didn't he's
not gonna cheat on his girlfriend
like these guys some guys don't cheat i
swear to god some guys don't cheat
and he could that man i he had a
girlfriend all through college they
broke up later
but
that man i saw girls throw themselves at
him all the time he never cheated ever
i mean they [ __ ] complain about all
the women being [ __ ] but then they want
to rack up huge [ __ ] body counts they
literally perpetuate the problem that
they complain about
no it's not
they don't complain about [ __ ] they
look it as women some guys will sleep
with the type of girl they would never
get in a relationship with we have to
understand that as girls
like there's a difference between
relationship attention and sexual
attention there's a very big difference
and no i don't i don't smoke i was the
prom queen in high school do i seem
charismatic enough to be a prom queen
don't get me wrong i'm a charmer i crack
a few jokes
you know how it is
but i i like men did not talk to me in
high school like i didn't
yeah
trust me i was
no i was not a prom queen anything okay
um do you own a pair of jordan oh the
newport thing it's a reference to uh
kiss black i mean all these questions
are alluding asking if
if you uh
are a knight rider if you i don't know
why it's so [ __ ] important
exactly but
these are all uh
i guess red flags or signals
of women that
sleep with black men
um my last boyfriend bought me jordan's
so yes
okay
all right
why is there some meaning behind those
there were some nice jordans too that
was like one of the first gifts he got
me yeah
wow
the reason i'm poking fun at you is
because just looking and listening to
you you would never ever know that your
ex-boyfriend was black oh my god that
happened when i was impression fit
because
it was actually it was kind of funny
because i mentioned like i was
mentioning my um
my
like
it's a long story like he was going to
come on the show for a second
and um so when i was mentioning it to
fresh um it was actually really funny i
i showed him and like after the show
he's like who is he like let me see his
page and i showed it to him and he was
like
you just say that like that's happened
before like yes
yeah then he like literally stared at me
for like five seconds i was like what
say it say it what's wha why is this
look on your face
[Music]
i'm not being exploited i have less
followers than him
i'm not
guys
you can talk to people you disagree with
it is not that hard
yeah well i don't
like
i always say like i i like white guys
too it's not really uh sure it's just
like am i filled like i think black guys
like like
me and i tend to like like guys that
like me
that makes sense of course yeah of
course yeah so you're telling me you get
a lot of looks from brothers
yeah i think it's just like the way i'm
built to be honest really men didn't
talk to you in high school it's because
they were scared oh no let me tell you
i've always been a go-getter look at so
you know some women have that sense of
like he has to chase me
not me no you know that ego the pride
that never quite
kicked in for me to be honest like so
from a young age i tried to go after the
guys i want unfortunately i was in fact
rejected and let me tell you an example
of one time where i was rejected there
was turnabout where you could ask a guy
to a dance
and there was a guy in my math class
that i was like this man is cute
and he was white just you guys know
because you guys would be like oh only
black guys no no this guy was white
and
i was like let me let me ask him what
kind of friends where my math class we
talk a little bit
i i think you're attractive sir
i made him a golden ticket in a
chocolate bar
to like ask him to dance
and this man
made fun oh my god it was so
embarrassing he
opened it i gave it to him before lunch
and he went at lunch to like open it and
he showed it to all his friends and
they're like laughing at it i'm like
getting ready because i was so
embarrassed back then
oh my god i was so embarrassed yeah
not a fan not a fan
so
oh so i mean i mean obviously you're
tall i mean what about your physical
stature
um i think
like this is just my experience but i
think white guys prefer like the
skinnier girls
and white and black guys prefer like the
curve like i have big thighs i played
volleyball my whole life and like
like a bigger
like
[ __ ]
very bottom like
i don't know that's where i like
i don't know no no i got you i got you i
i i i read you loud and clear
uh so you're what they call thick
yeah i guess um i don't like it because
that term is
girls always say that like when they're
actually just fat yeah but i'm actually
like in shape no you're like i mean i
haven't seen a full body picture of you
but you don't appear to that's a sweet
way to ask someone out literally it was
and then turned me down i was so
embarrassing
oh my god that was one of my i was like
none of these girls have ever been
rejected oh my gosh
be fat but yes um
you are the i guess you kind of are the
yeah i guess you would be i mean you've
seen devin's figure devin is oh yeah
devon
she is a better figure than me i'm not
even gonna lie like oh my girl
i gotta work out with you sometime yeah
man uh yeah dev uh she's built like a
black woman real talk like dude she's
built like dude she has the perfect
hourglass shape
strong muscular sheeply legs like oh boy
yeah yeah she's she she's got a nice
body to be sure
uh jblace11 says uh the fake white girls
you know it ah street fighter 88 says
she has a volleyball build uh is that
true yes no yeah yeah because volleyball
girls have like thicker thighs and like
because we're jumping all the time of
course of course and like so everything
all the actually i just talked about
going pro next year should i do it oh my
god life is
i hate having to make these decisions
you are like autumn
centric to be honest that makes sense
that makes sense
uh
a couple more super chats and then we
can close this out jg five dollars says
great show knight rider sound knight
writer sound has us dying over here
that's crazy uh
good mother five dollars says this
reminds me of what cynthia g does i'm
not a fan of the game
being uh this reminds me of what cynthia
g does i'm not a fan of the game being
played here so i guess good mother
uh is i guess she's a black woman who
does not like the fact that uh i'm
admitting uh to uh uh likened white
girls uh good mother i appreciate the
super chat but nope
wrong not my problem not my problem i
don't i don't really give a [ __ ] what
you think uh i don't care
i think what good mother has to
understand
is i've been through this my whole life
like i've been through this my whole
life uh good mother
cynthia g encourages
black women to swirl um i guess she's
saying that i am encouraging black men
to date outside their race
yeah i am uh because men i would never
encourage someone to date outside their
race
it's up to you i like do not care who
you date does not matter what they look
like uh
here's what it comes to here's what it
comes down to you want your viral moment
good mother i've never gone frail oh
here it is most black women have
attitudes most black women are
overweight those two oh my god i was
texting during this time i'm like not
even gonna lie to you i was not
listening so he's gonna ask me to
comment
and i only like half heard what he said
because i was like texting my guy friend
like oh my god i'm so sorry those two
factors alone are a reason are a big
reason why a lot of black men are dating
outside their race so you can not like
if you don't like what i do if you're
not a fan of the game being played here
this is not i'm not playing games i'm
i'm just telling men
hey man
go after that go after the women you
want just because you're mama black just
because your sister is black just
because you're black does not mean
does not
uh how can i put this does not require
you to date black women so i
respectfully disagree with what you're
saying not a fan of the game what is
playing games here
uh your thoughts uh pearl or do you want
to just stay out of this like devin does
um
yeah i'll just stay out of that
i was like what did he say
man i thought i was gonna trap you
see
so
speaking of games
yeah that's that's what i meant the
psychological [ __ ] mental gymnastic
game
the the toying the playing the
gaslighting the [ __ ] this is why
gaslighting is so misused he wasn't
gaslighting me
oh my god like
i can take a joke confusing the
interrupting after asking a question
that [ __ ] game
the trying to alter her [ __ ]
perception game
like my perception was not altered i
totally agree with all of that message
that he said
i totally uh
yeah pearl knew exactly what the [ __ ] he
meant
because she was not having fun
she was getting frustrated she was
embarrassed
i wasn't i mean i
i wasn't oh my gosh
and
she was
having a hard time thinking
so that those are signs what the
i was having a hard time thinking
and psychological abuse oh my god abuse
man this is this is why we don't get
taken seriously
when people are actually abused that was
not abuse i could have left that show at
any time if i was offended so
the the noises all the [ __ ]
yeah she was not
and plus
she got some [ __ ] terrible dating
advice
which
she didn't probably cost her
like if she was actually being herself
and not
taking pua advice
that that interaction could have gone
differently so
and that's unfortunate
so all those
playing with the [ __ ] emotions in
such a small amount of time that's what
these [ __ ] puas do
they get women all [ __ ] emotional and
confused and then they turn around is
that emotional and confused and try to
say that they're [ __ ] turned on
when they're just anxious
no they say you're turned on in any
interaction that goes well like any if
you just get along with a guy
yeah they're like oh they're trying to
i thought i was going to trap you yeah
um let's see uh definite g says dabooty
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah uh king life says
she got baby makers i don't know what
that is
um
geeky anomaly says yeah oh by the way um
uh pearl and i we are actually pearl was
noticing via the picture i had on the
wall
um so this is a this is a picture set
that i have of uh dev she decided to get
dressed up
and to um
and to make me dinner and yeah you guys
can you guys can see
you guys can see the bottom the bottom
left picture like she looks so skinny
i'm like girl
yeah she looks good she's got a nice uh
dude she has a nice ass she has her legs
truthfully man devin's got some of the
sexiest legs uh i've ever seen i mean
she's her legs are her legs are
unbelievable
um but um i mean i pay her personal i
mean dude i pay her personal trainer
uh 2400 a month to make sure she stays
that way um all right uh any final
thoughts before uh before we call this
thing off by the way that face she was
making that was
really
like disappointment
i think i was texting i'm not going to
lie to you
i mean i'm sure she has a lot to be
disappointed about in this small amount
of time
no i have a great life
for
for this i'm stressed though lately send
a donation in the chat also after this
i'll be reacting to michaela it's coming
up gentlemen that claims to be a [ __ ]
expert at reading body language and
behavior
like he seems to be completely [ __ ]
unaware of her
[ __ ] state this entire time
or maybe
maybe he wasn't unaware
he just didn't give a [ __ ] he was trying
to [ __ ] play a toy with her
no this was a fun show today yeah it was
it was it was a it was a lot of fun we
learned a lot
um
my advice to you pearl get your ears
pierced get your ears my ears are pure
this is the funny part i just never wear
earrings
i go to and from the gym so much it's
just like not like normally i'll have an
hour practice during the day and then i
have like five hours in between so
that's why i always look
like homeless because i'm like in
between two hour practices
because you're attractive like you're
conventionally attracted i've never been
called conventionally attractive in my
life but i'll take it all you don't need
makeup all you just get your ears
pierced get a couple of studs in there
maybe put on some eye makeup
and uh i think brothers will start
looking a little bit more
directional
i mean
don't be ashamed don't be ashamed ain't
nothing wrong ain't nothing wrong with
brothers looking to regression i'm just
trying to tell you hey if you want to
increase your pool of potential suitors
those are a couple of things that uh i
do i will when i'm ready to date again i
just right now i'm like
i gotta
that is going to do it for this edition
of pick me
uh with pearl um in less than two hours
in an hour oh wait a minute shout out to
jj
[Music]
says uh welcome to chat privileges uh
jade if you would at jj to welcome him
to the tsr family in an hour and a half
in an hour and a half elite level game
with coach everett
overton we are going to talk about how
to deal with women with red flags we're
going to open up the phone lines you are
not going to miss this good mother i
would encourage you to call in i would
love to hear what you have to say about
this
thank you guys all for tuning in and
yeah
what's up guys
yeah
he did encourage me to call in i didn't
though
jordan peterson's daughter is next after
this i'm reacting to that guy but
no i didn't call in
okay
next okay so i already watched this
interview
and if i was smart i probably would have
wrote down like time stamps just make
this shorter
um i have not seen rollo's
interpretation of it so i'm just going
to react
and then show you my interpretation
and then i'll react to willows maybe i
don't like him to me uh ben shapiro
found a liking to me so i thought oh
great
and so you know
talking to him here and there you know i
never want to be the guy who's always
asking for too much but you know someone
says they're gonna help hey why not yeah
if it's ben yeah yeah and so i was like
man i have a dream
mr shapiro
and my dream is i want to get dr jordan
peterson on my podcast it'd be a dream
of mine i gotta get him on the phone he
said you know what i'll help you out
i'll reach out to his people this that
in the third
and uh you know to connect me to him so
i think he sent an email to the the
assistant before the woman who got
pregnant recently we're back
before rebecca you sent an email to the
person i was like you know
trying to connect and they were like
yeah you know he's you know kind of out
of commission right now because of the
tour the side of the third so maybe
later
so i was like man this sucks
and i and every after weeks i would go
back to the email just read it
frustration and then one day roommates
is too big not to have time stamps i
know i don't either
okay
but i'm not as big as them they got like
half a million subs get you someone to
get get me times let me just read it one
more time i read the email one more time
at the bottom i saw that ben had
forwarded the email to you
and then at the bottom of your header i
saw your phone number
how that happened and so i was like you
know what
let me just try
so i reached out to you he was able to
connect you were so friendly you were so
kind and then and obviously throughout
the years always check on you and the
family and so no i think i think what i
love the most about
what you stand for what your dad stands
for is that some people you meet their
characters online and they're super
amazing super fun super great online but
then you meet them in person and they're
not the same yeah yeah yeah but i really
feel like you and your father both
embody people who are amazing
individuals online and really impact a
lot of lies but at the same time in
person you guys are genuine honest
authentic people so i want to share that
with you thank you thank you very much
no problem that's really nice no problem
so michaela i know who you are so for
those who don't know who you are can you
give a bit of an elevator pitch synopsis
about you yourself okay elevator pitch
so i have my own podcast michaela
peterson podcast and one of the things i
focused on in that podcast is a series
called opposing views
where i talk about a contentious subject
so something people argue over so like
abortion or gun rights or covet or
vaccines and then i'll have an expert on
one side come on and talk about it and
then an expert on the other side uh
that i've found really interesting
because i love it yeah yeah so that's
fun so that's what i'm doing i also run
my dad's like brand management i guess
you could say so that's like online
products pr
and then the finances that have to do
with that the podcast production social
media so that actually takes up the
majority of my time i've been doing the
podcast on the side but it's growing
and then i'm writing a book
i have a daughter i have a four-year-old
daughter scarlett shout out scarlett
yeah and i think a lot of people
probably have heard of me online because
of the lion diet which is this all meat
diet i'm on for an autoimmune disorder
okay so that's the that's the elevator
pitch that was the short form version i
love it i love it so there's so many
directions i feel like this episode is
going to go today
and but i want to start i want to start
from the very beginning because i think
um a lot of people know of you
but they know of you like you were born
at like 22.
you know
it is oh there comes michael and there
she is but i want i want to go back i
want to go back so michaela peterson
should i skip this part
because i just want to talk about the
male 1 tears
let's see
to wake up i was like i'm full of energy
i looked different
i think when
kids get famous like you see them get
really
you let me know what time stamp i should
skip to i want to get to the part where
they talk about
red pill yeah it's weird it is pretty
weird even going to shows
it's pretty weird because like growing
up i did he did teach me about you know
different mythological stories the
psycho psychological significance of the
bible and like those were conversations
we had at home and he goes on like
longer
lectures now but
like that was what happened at the
dinner table yeah and i just thought
wow if you grow up in that i had like i
had no idea
that anybody else did anything
differently and i think until i was 23
yeah which is late you'd think but no
that matters
that makes sense because even for me
it's like my i i consider my dad a
rockstar you probably i know you can say
your dad a rock star and i remember
growing up i just thought everyone's dad
was like this yeah yeah yeah you know so
i can only imagine like you said then
you eventually start meeting people and
experiencing life and like whoa you
didn't get life lessons every five
minutes yeah
yeah my dad was gone a lot to be honest
but when he was around he gave very good
advice like great advice
like my dad
yeah i love my dad enough you know
so
how did that realization happen for you
okay so
when i was in grade six
i
not discovered ebay but like for myself
i discovered ebay i was like whoa you
can get really cheap things
yeah yeah so it's like okay ebay is
great i was like dad like get a load of
ebay like this is awesome uh you can buy
gold like you can buy all these things
on ebay and so he starts so then he he
went on ebay and he started buying
soviet art because you couldn't get art
out of the soviet union
for you couldn't get out art out of the
soviet union when it was the soviet
union and then people had these stores
of amazing paintings like in garages and
attics that they couldn't sell and so
when ebay
came around and
people in behind the wall kind of
figured out ebay they started selling
art and dad was like okay i'm gonna
snatch up like all the art i possibly
can because this is gonna be worth a
bunch in the future and he spent
like a large portion of each day from
like a couple of years looking at soviet
union art and our house ended up
completely filled with art which drove
my mom crazy
but by completely filled i mean there
were gaps like this big between the
paintings oh my god so at one point we
counted 104 paintings my brother and i
went around counting paintings
so i think it first occurred to me when
i went over to other people's houses and
i was like
we had 37 different paint colors on the
walls so each room had like five or six
different paint colors
and
it was covered in paintings there were
paintings on the ceiling in some rooms
oh my god yeah it was wild we had masks
on the walls and things um i came home
from university one time i was lying in
bed and a painting of lennon fell on
i was just
so
i think going to other people's houses
and then
seeing what it looks oh my god
respectfully get to it
i need to order one of these mic stands
oh i think i have the same one but i
can't figure out where to order another
because i got it from like a store and
now i'm in the uk i literally i i was i
i'm usually pride myself about being
very tapped in to internet culture
but it wasn't until recently okay a
little deeper into the conversation
not only is is your father what's
interesting is not only is your father
vastly misrepresented by the media i
didn't know up until recently how
misrepresented you were yeah
i lit i i was i i'm usually pride myself
about being very tapped in to internet
culture
but it wasn't until recently and hearing
some of the things you were talking
about i was like i did not know she was
being misrepresented by the media and so
what would you say
are some of the
misrepresentations of you
that you're consistent you've been
consistently here within the past couple
of years
so i think at the beginning it was
that i was selling this
all meat diet that i'm on
which i'm not because it's really hard
to make money off of telling people to
they could potentially change their diet
to eating meat that's not right so so
that was part of it was like oh she's
lying about that like i had the media
say i'd made up having like i was like i
have my hip replaced my ankle replaced
like i've got scars like this isn't a
story it's not like my knee hurt now it
doesn't hurt anymore
uh so that was the beginning but that's
kind of understandable if you come
across someone who's like i only eat
meat he's like okay i get it i get it
fair enough um and then my family got
really sick so my mom
got cancer and my dad
ended up on
after stopping the antidepressants which
we'd both been taking for a long time um
went into antidepressant withdrawal
which we didn't know was a thing
and he got stuck on benzodiazepines so
literally
couldn't stop taking them without going
into severe withdrawal and it wasn't
like i want more it was like physical
like a horror show from physical
withdrawal
and
um the medical system didn't know what
to do with him
so like at all we went to specialists
and they kept trying to take the
medication away but you can't do it if
someone's stuck if they've physically
adapted to taking it right
it's dangerous to take it away that
quickly and so i started researching
because i had gone through really severe
anti-depressant withdrawal and was like
that's what it looks like like oh like
dad's really sick and he was really sick
like it it was really bad he was
completely out of commission
and
and we went to a bunch of different
doctors about a bunch of different
hospitals and nobody helped like they
made it worse
uh and he ended up getting stuck in a
hospital in canada
and
i ended up
kind of taking on the responsibility of
getting him better because i was like
i've been through the medical system for
like 15 years i know when you get a
doctor and they don't yes that's the one
thing is you don't even
the medical system like doctors are just
people and you can have shitty doctors
too
people cheat their way through med
school be careful
my mom's dad basically died because a
doctor like didn't diagnose him soon
enough even though he went to him like
multiple times i don't know what they're
doing because they're just people right
um
and i'm gonna kind of put my life on
hold and try and figure this out because
my mom had just recovered from cancer
and i was like she can't deal with i
don't know
where i don't know how cancer works but
i was like this cannot be good for her
seeing her husband like this and so i
kind of took on that responsibility and
dad disappeared for a while so he was
like completely out of commission for
almost two years yeah really bad
and i've been running his like brand
like i said so that's pr and social
media and helping produce the podcast
and i was like how are you supposed to
explain this to the public so not only
did i have to deal with dad being sick
and my family being
pretty destroyed by it but i'd be like
what's like this how do you explain this
um
and i think because we kind of
disappeared for a while um i got a lot
of flack online so i had a lot of people
who are like oh yeah she's taken over
her brand uh her dad's brand she's i
don't know like it twitter was a nast
twister twitter can be a nasty place so
there's a lot of just like
me
the portrayal was me going out and
partying and taking over dad's brand and
forcing him on an all meat diet
while he's sick
and that was like normally i don't
really care about things online but
because my parents were so sick i was
like this is bad like this hurts and if
he doesn't get better
then i'm going to get blamed
which is really screwed up because this
is not my fault at all
and i'm just trying hard to make things
right
fortunately um fortunately he's better
now and that took it took two years of
trying to figure out how to get somebody
off of benzodiazepines without them
sorry i'm i'm waiting for him to get to
her to get to the red pill stuff
i don't know anything about medicine so
i'm just gonna not my experiencing
um which is something people should know
about because there are a lot of people
on psych meds and they're really hard to
get off of
so
anyway i seem to have navigated that and
dad's better and now he's on tour and
that's over but i think the
misrepresentation in the media part of
it is
that i'm this like controlling person
that's taking advantage of my dad when
that's not the case at all
no yeah that's interesting because i
think
you know when your dad first started
getting sick that's when i first reached
out to you and you were always somebody
who was always so
responsive and you know i was you know
to give me occasional updates and you
know send prayers to the family so in my
mind i was just like this is just a an
amazing daughter taking care of her
family and like there was always a sense
of like from our conversation to brief
text conversations always a sense of
just like you just care you know like
you were just like like this was nothing
of your fault you know and so
upon you know months later you know that
your father's getting better better you
know people are talking to me about him
getting healthier you're telling me he's
getting better you know then i met
jordan you know after you know rebecca
had her child and you know set up the
podcast so and my brand was just like oh
wow like everything just seems like it's
going good
until recently you know i was watching a
video with you on it we can talk a
little bit more about that later but and
then you were just saying how people
were blaming you
for
what happened with your father
it almost like i'm interested in what
rolo thinks about this because i did say
some stuff that like kind of heavily
insinuated that
she was to blame but he's like an old
guy like
he can make decisions for himself he's
clearly
you know
very smart
[Music]
there's a lot of crazy deductions i can
see happen in life you know i mean like
i can kind of understand
why you would assume a b and c for some
ideas but i was like
how do you guys think
she's trying to
harm her own like how demonic of a child
you think jordan peterson raised that
his own daughter would be trying to do
this to him and and so to me
it was i don't know it was just it was
just so fascinating
how
the internet and these narratives can
just so falsely especially for people to
be jordan peterson fans know how he's
falsely portrayed by the media
and totally opposite of everything he
stands for by the wrong by the media and
then for you to do the same thing to his
daughter that to me was just like
how in the world does that even add up
yeah
that's strange i don't know if it was
dad's fans exactly i think it's more
convenient for people who are like oh no
he's a charlatan or he's teaching values
but he doesn't stand by them because
look at his daughter like i get that a
lot online it's like oh don't take him
seriously because look at his daughter
yeah
what but what and and and and this is
the point where i'm just like
okay
what
is making these guys upset so much about
what you're doing yeah
that is a very good question like what
kind of person do you have to be to be
but they're not upset and this is where
this is where she's get
going off we get emotional as women i
don't think it's a bad thing i think it
can be our superpower but here's the
thing
rollo
was not upset he was talking about a
dynamic that happened
and he was using you as an example he
wasn't upset
but i mean if it was me i probably
wouldn't appreciate it either to be fair
angry at somebody's daughter yeah
especially as a man
just to put it out there it's a little
weird yeah
i don't know what it feels like some
kind of jealousy
relationship jealousy or something
because i'm pretty close with my like my
family's pretty close all together yeah
i think if i was to guess
i think there's
a
idea
and this get and now we're getting into
some of the uh other parts of the
internet
but there there is an idea
of how a man should be in a lot of
people's minds
and i think your father's ideals
represent a lot of what a man should be
in a very traditional sense
you know taking responsibility providing
protecting being a leader being
dangerous in a good way all these good
virtues that for those
people of that traditional bent
there's this idea where oh they like
that message
so i think what they're
they're thinking is that okay that
traditionalist type of guy which your
father is not as con
you know traditionally conservative that
they think he is but that could con a
traditional kind of guy should have a
daughter yeah yeah yeah he was like this
amish
princess yeah yeah yeah
who was just so reserved to say oh no oh
no like my dad is more like traditional
my parents are more traditional but
i mean there's 10 of us you think we're
all came out the same oh god now this
who's so that who does and so i think
there there's like why doesn't michaela
not follow her dad's teachings i mean
guys
did you follow every single thing your
parents told you
of course not
what do you mean like
i i have nine siblings okay
do all of them
follow what my dad said to do no of
course not i'm my dad's favorite though
i don't care what anyone says i am my
dad's favorite
disconnect with who they expect you to
be because of the way they view maybe
the values your dad is teaching i think
that is spot on actually yeah i don't
think i've thought about that i'm
actually enjoying this otherwise i would
skip to 54 but i might later if the
conversation goes to where i i get bored
before i think that's spot on and it's
funny because so my dad got written up a
lot for me like oh he's a well whatever
he's anything but like a massage i'm
blocking the account that always
pretends to be donovan sharp that is not
cool it's not misogynist was one of them
i was like that's most definitely not
true right like when he had grad
students he had female grad students and
all like he only prioritized male grad
students and
i mean
he put me in charge of like of his brand
right
and
and he it's
like i didn't do that
when you're a public figure people
pointed out yeah of course comes with
the territory he asked for help like a
whole bunch of help and then i helped
him
so
i think if my dad was a public figure i
absolutely would work for him
i still might someday you never know
that's right and but i kind of
understand i guess where people are
coming from because he does put forward
like traditional
ideals which i think are
are valuable because i think that's
i think it's valuable and i think myself
i've had a hard time like navigating
relationships
and being being female but somebody
who's also more inclined to do more
business and have our own podcasts and
things which i don't think is the
traditional yeah um okay
this is where i relate to michaela a lot
i don't this is what i say on my channel
i don't consider myself like a super
traditional woman
because a lot of [ __ ] that like other
girls are interested in i'm just like
not like i'm not really interested in
like makeup and hair like i'm more
interested in like sports and like
taking that to the highest level and
that's more of like a male dominated
field i'm on youtube which tends to be
male dominated in a space that's male
dominated
and i can work like i'm a hard worker
and i've always always always been
complimented on my work ethic from like
a very
young age i don't work smart that's my
problem
but
that i i when she was talking about this
because i watched this earlier i just
remember thinking like yes this is
exactly how i feel a lot traditional
woman so i can see how people get
confused by that
online yeah for sure and and to me it's
also you know all these ideas are fun
because i look at it like even even
even a man who's a very strong leader
um you are you older than your brother
yeah yeah so a man who's a very strong
leader who's competent who's successful
who's driven
all his values
if he's a half decent enough father will
go to his children yes because that is
what my dad taught me from a young age
work hard at whatever you do work hard
work hard work hard
and i love my dad so of course i'm gonna
listen and especially if he has
daughters and they're the oldest
daughters
you know what i mean those those that's
so true i was the oldest daughter
sort of i had to adopt it but
anyone who knows my family's stories
knows
that like we kind of have a weird story
but growing up i was the oldest girl in
the house
yeah
those values would be inviting her as
well
so i've seen you know yeah even like
kind of even with the the whole like
trump ivanka dynamic where it's like
that that girl i am i expect her to be
driven
yup
yup that's how i feel expect her to be a
go-getter i expect her to embody that
spirit of assertiveness you know that
her father has as well and so i think
there's a part where
a lot of people don't realize what how
did you expect her to grow up
if her father was it was always teaching
independence and and responsibility and
proactivity like how did you expect her
to grow up you know what i mean like you
expect her to be this this nun like
you know and so that's where to me
what am i capping about
made sense why you were such a
independent
in a positive way go-getters person it
made sense to me
um but i think for people who don't
understand what it's like to have a
father my dad's like that and he gave my
my my sister that dna as well so
i understand that but i guess for people
who don't understand that that's what
confuses them and that's when they think
oh she's going against her family value
she's going against this and doing her
own thing and rebelling and partying and
doing that seven though because they
just think that you're the opposite of
the idea of a woman that they believe a
doctor jordan b peterson should raise
that was good i'm a clinical
psychologist it's really good that was
really good i think i think that's
exactly right yeah i also like instagram
isn't an ideal way to portray yourself
like i'll post one picture of me
drinking one time it's like she parties
all the time it's like i
i work all the time like i work all
see okay
this is how i feel
because it's like what what is it we
first have to define what a party girl
is right how often do you have to drink
to be defined as a party girl
that's the question
because but i wonder a lot of times when
rollo talks about like the party phase i
i think it's like different for every
girl like every girl has a different
version of the party phase like some
girls sleep with like 50 guys some girls
just like enjoy the male attention
some girls are a flirt some girls drink
a lot like
i don't know that's what that's what i
think of
but when you first listen to his content
because again you have to listen to a
lot of rollo's content before you really
understand it all the time it's
ridiculous i need to not do that as much
right but
if you only get an idea of a person from
their social media platform and then
they post stupid photos sometimes then
that's not ideal yeah
and to me i think you know i what blows
my mind
is i'm always i'm always interested in
like
if you as an individual understand
how a picture
is a small
snap blah blah blah i'm gonna go to 54.
um because that's where you said that
okay
schools i went to two were art schools
and so they are super loud
yeah so
i had some there were some arguments in
his school and things i remember yeah
when facebook came around and got into a
facebook argument because that was it
um a woman's decision in her past
dictate her future absolutely the best
predictor of future behavior is past
behavior absolutely a hundred percent um
but i think when michaela gets mad it's
because she's like
i don't even do anything like i work all
the time
i'm not a [ __ ] all of you guys are
calling me hoes
you saw me at a concert last year
i don't even think i went to a concert
last year what concert
the thing yeah yeah with someone about
it was about feminism too in high school
you're like you're the worst person on
the internet it's like that's dramatic
but so for friends
i had a tricky time
making girlfriends up until more
recently
and i think that's because a lot of the
people i was associating with were super
left leaning and i was just like
disagreeable and like
argumentative that doesn't make like
very good friends
um now
most of my friends it's hard like i have
a lot of friends from social media now
yeah so a lot of my podcasting friends
have pretty similar views to me
but that's pretty new yeah everybody
kind of back from toronto would say
pretty s center but a little bit more
left like i definitely have
disagreements with um some of my friends
back there yeah so hard to say
so i know you you you've you've gotten
really deep into the men's space and the
men's dating space with like even the
some of the crazy red pill content and
all types of
foolishness that goes on about in that
space what
how did you find that and like what
happened someone said rolo just had a
disrespectful take on what her day what
she did compared to that lady who killed
her child
i think if we want to be emotional about
it that's that's how
you can take it i don't think it was
disrespectful i think rolo was talking
about a dynamic and he said so many
times during the interview i am not
saying that she wanted to kill her child
but this is the same dynamic
and i think it's emotional
and it's emotional to come up even when
he clearly communicated he is not saying
that she wanted to kill her child
to be oh no it's disrespectful oh my god
it's like
okay
it's been your experience seeing it
learning it hearing about it all that
stuff
uh okay the red pill space are you
talking about rolo yeah oh yeah yeah
like all those like all that
content over there because i feel like
i think you were talking about
especially in the interview how you you
were researching it and you were
learning about it and you were curious
about it i was just curious like how did
you
i think it makes i have an idea of how
you got there but i'm curious to like
you know
how did you really get there and then
like what is some of like your your your
thought process about just some of that
type of content okay well i think
specifically for rolo tomasi i'd heard
of the rational mail i think i heard
about it in high school interesting yeah
i i think that was the first time i
heard a mention so i and i just heard
you know certain people bring it up you
know whenever and i was like okay well
that's interesting if he's doing the
same i didn't know very much about him i
was like if he's doing the same thing
that like robert glover is doing
yes
i don't know who robert glover is
should i know that name yeah but that
was kind of my thinking it was like if
he's doing that kind of
that kind of thing like maybe that would
be an interesting podcast so i think it
was just like naivety
so i hadn't actually like sat down i
don't actually really watch podcasts i
have a podcast but i don't really watch
podcasts
uh or listen to podcasts so i think it
may be just naivety yeah and it was like
i thought it was kind of the same thing
it was like oh if you're teaching men to
take more responsibility
and
just
i like i understand like the hatred
uh i think you're wrong i don't think
it's the same thing
as whoopi goldberg saying the holocaust
wasn't about race sorry don't think it's
the same thing at all towards men that's
kind of going on on the left i was like
well if it's not that and you're
then that's good but i i think i just
didn't do my research properly
[Music]
what has been like after you know
the conversation kayla if you ever want
to get coached for one of these
interviews i could coach you better than
whoever the hell prepared you
after doing more research what are some
of the things that you you've come to
realize about some of that space i'm
just curious how you process it
i think that
for like
the serious like red pill depending on
the person but some of those people are
angry like really angry like usually
when i have a duh
it's the internet
there's always angry people conversation
with someone and i'll bring like
left-wing people on the podcast too and
generally speaking i can have a
conversation with anybody and
generally speaking we leave feeling like
okay that was a reasonable conversation
and with
rolo in particular it was like that
didn't feel nothing about that felt good
we didn't leave on the same level at all
and
i think some of those people are there's
some like anger towards women going on
and that's the criticism red pill
community gets too it's like why do you
hate women but like
and and initially i thought that was
kind of a misrepresentation in the media
like everything else is a
misrepresentation
but
i think that there are some red-pilled
people that really don't like women and
you can see by like you can see it it's
not it's not that they don't like women
they
they have a point of view about women's
nature
that is pretty offensive if you don't
understand it
like that is that is how i would
describe it like if you don't understand
what they're talking about
you probably will be offended
and hate yourself a little bit because
they're just like
women
do this they do this wrong they do this
wrong they do this wrong and they'll
just give you like a million things that
you cannot say
if she says this she really means that
and you'll be like what
what they'll be like hoop earrings those
are the death
oh my god i can't believe she wore the
hoop earrings to this oh my gosh
clearly yeah and it's not for the
betterment like
teaching people
that all women are a certain way or all
men are a certain way
uh
i don't think that that's
going to actually make people make
things better make people get along
better yeah yeah no that makes sense i
think um
you know my experience in the men's
space i've been i've been just i've i
watch everybody i i try to read almost
everything you know and you know there's
there's good and bad everywhere and
there's extreme
you know red pill there's nothing wrong
with this it's a [ __ ] communicator let's
see your communication skills sir like
it's always get out of here all this
stuff and i don't i don't want to paint
everybody in the same light
but to me the most fascinating thing is
like if you were to
rollo's biggest problem is he doesn't
come off as likable respectfully i like
rolo
i think he's cool but like when you
first listen to him he he just doesn't
come off as like super
likable
and that to me is his biggest issue
if you really listen to his full
broadcast he's a very good communicator
and he actually explains his points very
well but most people
aren't going to watch a full broadcast
unless they see your clip and they're
like oh i like this guy let me watch
more
and
yeah i just i don't think he comes off
as overly likable
like uh i would i would really describe
it as like
the the enemy of a red pill guy
is a it's like a left-wing feminist
that's like his arch rifle yeah yeah
yeah but if you let a left-wing feminist
tell you about men
and what men do to women
and how men behave and what men are like
and you were to change the word man with
woman yeah it sounds exactly exactly the
same it's exactly the same exact same
and so one of the one of the advantages
of i'm not trying to be the female rolo
oh my gosh
i do not know as many stats as that man
i'm sorry
i don't
i woke up and chose violence today
yeah i don't know
what we did was in the year 2019 we went
on tour with one of my mentors who's
actually a female dating coach so he um
besides matthew he's like the largest
female dating coach in the world what's
his name stefan labosierre okay yeah
i'll show you social media he has like
five million followers around the social
media he's cool really really well
respected and he's a very positive
person
and so uh so stefan you know he's this
rock star i was on tour and i was a
video guy so i wasn't teaching i wasn't
lecturing i was just
recording and observing
and then you would see some of these
women the the ones who've been hurt the
ones who who have this very dogmatic
belief you see them share it and you see
them express their their hurt and their
anger towards men and
and i do think that the red pill does
give get you some angry men because
you're constantly bombarded with this
like clip after clip after clip of woman
being like crazy hypergamous or crazy
high standards and it makes you think
that the world is like actually like
that now
don't get me wrong there are some girls
in the world that are like that i'm not
even gonna cap to you but
it's like never that extreme in the real
world
what happens is when you
when you get hurt
all of a sudden you look for you look
for validation for your hurt so now
when you see somebody do something right
you don't notice it but when you see
someone do something wrong you notice it
so for example yeah they can see 50 guys
open their doors for their wife
they won't notice that but they see one
guy yelling and screaming at his wife
they notice that it and it reinforces
their beliefs
and so i would notice i'll be like dang
and we would try to talk to the women be
like yo there's there's so much more to
men there's than what media paints it
and you try to open their eyes and
they're stuck
they're not listening to you they're
stuck in their ways and then you know
doing what we're ten dollars thank you
so much guys consider dropping a
donation my goal is a thousand dollars
to get four more mics and another sound
board to host those mics
right now we're at one
like 70 i want to say 170 bucks so thank
you thank you thank you thank you you're
doing for men you see that you're like
you're just like her
these women that we would meet on tour
were hurt who were bitter who were
nihilistic who were bent on all men are
like this and this is how they are
they're here to hurt women and screw you
over like and you see these guys like
that
and it was just it was it was really
interesting and and it's and it's really
upsetting to be honest with you yeah
it's really sad yeah hold on guys i got
it with somebody else right
it's hard to be alone like life is
tricky
comments on my phone it is sad that's
interesting that you could see people
open up like that yeah and i think
okay
uh
um
sorry my little brother just texted me
his ex my little brother's ex commented
on one of my tick tocks talking [ __ ]
about my brother and i'm like
lady
if you're mad he wouldn't make you his
girlfriend just say that
just say that like
i'm sorry you chose to hook up with him
for a year
without a title like that is not my
fault that is not like
you gave him easy
hookup
like that
and now she's like he manipulated me i'm
like girl a year
a year
sorry
it just pissed me off so i screenshotted
it and texted it to him and i was like i
can respond if you want should i
i thought about like replying to the
comment with the video and being like
look lady you slept with him like
the first time we you came over to our
house
off of tinder like what what did you
what were you expecting ma'am
anyways um
okay
oh wait this isn't um hold on
go back okay sorry
i think to me it's just like
when you when
with guys in that that far red pill
space when you tell them they're you
guys are hurt men yeah
it triggers them yeah because it makes
them feel like you're emasculating them
but i think we don't understand like
what hurt means
to be hurt is to be human
and a lot of times when you have a
visceral attitude towards somebody it
usually comes when you really value and
love a person so i always say that's why
some of your arguments with your
siblings are some of the most
contentious or spouses intentions
because the more you feel the more you
potentially can idolize someone the more
you can potentially demonize individuals
as well
so if a lot of these guys it's like
they put so much into women and into all
women so i want to say women into all
women and when that woman hurts him in
any way shape whether it's you know
something as simple as she just didn't
want him because she wasn't interested
to where she heard him or cheated on him
now that creates this anger and hurt
animosity towards everybody to where now
you go online and all you want to do is
hear stories that confirm what you felt
you know yeah and and we would even see
with even with our channel we could do a
video about you know we do video to help
men you know
pick the right person also to avoid the
wrong person but all my friends in the
space will tell you you get 10 extra
views
emphasizing negative traits people
conflict yeah yeah that's true then you
do emphasizing the positive traits
because so many people just want to sit
in the negativity
yeah yeah yeah even even for thumbnails
i know that if you put something like
how to have you know put something
negative on the thumbnail yeah it's not
like how to become hotter it's like how
to become less ugly that's a bad example
but that one will make the the ugly one
will make
will get more views people are also
evolutionarily
predisposed to avoiding negativity right
so it's just anything negative is going
to stand out i think people remember
negative experiences more too
so
that makes sense yeah because and then
people don't realize and and and i was
trying to explain i try to explain to
the guys in my audience the capitalistic
nature behind some of the red pill
content
and
and yeah
yeah yeah i'm curious what
i don't think
rollo is really capitalistic at all
because i think if he was he would have
gone about his [ __ ] a completely
different way
his [ __ ] is not
no i would say that's wrong why did i
fly why did that flicker in your mind
i'm curious oh well when i when i had
the conversation with rolo and i was
like i had an issue with your thumbnail
you're like you made a thumbnail i was
comparing comparing me to someone who'd
killed their child yeah and i was like
that
i didn't like that that wasn't very nice
right and he was like yeah but it gets
he like full on said it gets more clicks
you know how youtube is and i was like
well
okay
but like maybe that's a little bit far
but
he was explaining a dynamic
right like i get it he's like well yeah
but i know how to make thumbnails and
like people want to see people argue
online and he was like full-on full-on
said
he makes up stories kind of makes up or
plays into stories or makes these
comparisons
to get more views because people like
that type of content and i was like well
people like like i don't just because
people like to to watch that kind of
thing doesn't mean that you should be
devoting your life to making that kind
of content like what kind of life is
that yeah i know that and
i don't like that i don't know why i
don't like it because i just don't
i just don't think that's accurate like
that that is i watch the same
conversation and it's not fresh enough
in my head but that is not
what i think he said and that's the
thing i was i try to explain guys as a
person who
you know obviously i don't affiliate
myself with the red pill management for
any of the other stuff as a person who
has a lot of friends in this space and
they tell me everything like if anyone's
in the space who makes
a significant amount of money i know
them personally
and interesting
and we talk about everything
and one thing is clear as day
is that
they
i remember watching a video with logan
paul and logan paul made a point where
he's saying there's difference between
making good content and making good
youtube content
because you can make a good video
but if it's not you know effects well
and thumbnail well entitled well yeah
won't do well on youtube doesn't mean
divorce damages children and she had no
problem doing it to be with an alpha
see this is this is where i get
because there's a million reasons for
divorce and i don't think every single
time a girl divorces guides because she
thinks she can do better right like
sometimes i just think people aren't
meant to be together
however
this time it kind of seemed like that
i'm not even gonna it's not a good video
this means that
to do good on youtube you know you must
know how to hack youtube and hack the
audience's mind via youtube and so
a lot of the people they realize i can
either
do
youtube hacky videos and make fifty
thousand a month
or i can do more positive good content
and make ten
when you're young
or when you're just trying to just you
when you're really just making content
for money
why would you why would you sacrifice
forty thousand dollars you know so a lot
of people i don't think rolo does it for
money though that's like fresh and fit
if you talk about fresh and fit that's i
would agree they like hack youtube they
do that but alone
in the space it's like
they know there's just it's this three
four five extra money i can i can tell
it to you for a fact
i know if i wanted to make money
there's a certain kind of video i know
for a fact if i do it
it's gonna make money but that video
will perpetuate the negativity that a
lot of guys feel yeah that performs the
best
oh that's tricky that's really tricky
i've been trying for for thumbnail
optimization because my dad
titles all his videos and i was like dad
like i get where you're coming from as
but
this isn't going to work like you've got
an excellent podcast here but it should
be getting four times as many views the
thumbnail's not optimized the title is
not optimized can we just do it like a
little bit catchier yeah it's a little
bit catchier and there's this really
fine line between like
well i i mean i just i've just decided i
if i do content that's like i don't do
content that i don't like to do
for money because that makes me feel bad
and money doesn't make me feel better
than that bad feeling but i don't this
has nothing to do with rolo rollo has
been doing this for 20 years if the man
was doing it for money he would have
monetized a different way a long time
ago so i just like can't do that right
and my dad's
the same way i think
i i get it though especially for younger
people that's that's tricky to navigate
because it's a game right more that's
like yeah look how much money i made
it's not oh i'm perpetuating a negative
stereotype and making the entire world a
little worse right it's just like making
a bit i'm making money exactly and that
point as you brought up is especially
true for the younger guys i know a lot
of guys in the space you know there's
the older guys you know like the ones
you describe but a lot of the guys hold
on i'm about to send something to my
brother we're talking about his girl
hold on
okay adam this is what i wanted to say i
want to be like lady
if you miss him just say that
like it is not his fault that you chose
to sleep with him for a year
over a year i think
without the title of a relationship he
could not have made it any more clear
that he didn't want you
like and now that's his fault
you you chose it
take accountability for your actions you
it was an l you took an l sometimes in
life we take l's take it in peace
don't be commenting on my tick tock [ __ ]
like get the i will block you [ __ ]
sorry
sorry i'm like super normal
because in the space we'll have a large
audience they're the younger guys and
when you're young you don't really have
that
that responsibility for what you're
putting out it's kind of like it's kind
of like being uh um you you view
yourself as a musician
if you a musician knows
even though it's just art
you're influencing how people think but
in your brain it's always just music
right so you can put out whatever
content paint whatever picture to be
able to sell albums and we all know
that's relatively like my brother's
calling me should i answer i'll answer
what i'm like if you miss him just say
that oh my god i was so mad last night
but i was like
what if she was like oh he manipulated
me i'm like for a year
a year and a half i'm like he can't
manipulate you that long at some point
it's a choice
i talked to her longer than i dated any
girl
like
like this was a this was a decision that
you made
don't come crying to his sister on my
platform because i'm telling a nice
story about adam i'm telling a nice
story what
i told the video i was like telling
people my i did i'm doing a series where
i'm like fun stories about my siblings
and i was like talking about how you
helped amelia up that mountain for 10
000 feet on a bum knee i'm like their
sub superior genetic ability like adam
is so nice i would not i would have told
her to walk
and
and she's like this is the same man
that
like said he could manipulate me i'm
like how how lady also i'm on live
having this conversation i'm just
letting you know
on youtube she's not going to see it
okay well i don't care i'm like
lady
i hate it it drives me crazy when women
look at have i ever taken an l yeah
but take the l and move on
don't
don't [ __ ] to his sister that you took
an l like get out
she reached out to you me go complain to
him
well she can't i ever blocked
but
that's besides the point
it's just really fun i'm like if you
miss him just say that like
at this point you hit him
i'd probably take her back for a little
bit
i'll be like
wait wait because you you would i was
like he had a whole girlfriend after you
like
yeah
don't mention that part wait she doesn't
know oh
[ __ ] though
so
basically i was only sleeping with her
for
that amount of time because i don't
really i changed my ways and i didn't
really enjoy sleeping with multiple
people at once so i kind of stopped that
okay i was only sleeping with her and
then um
when she
asked to be exclusive that was literally
the week i decided all right i'm gonna
go [ __ ] this new girl
stop parking right here
oh so she didn't like that and that was
your that was your last girlfriend
yeah like look at it honey sometimes
it's not you
sometimes like
look it we can't we can't take w's every
single time just take the l and move on
i'm sorry
i'm sorry my brother's out of your
league get out
no
you you took a w you got her time and
attention for a year and a half with no
commitment
the next girl yeah that was probably an
l that
probably not really i think it ended
fairly like each side it's just an l for
my wasted time should i respond i was
going to ask you because i really wanted
to say something [ __ ] like like if you
miss him
very
[Laughter]
you sent it to me during our morning
meeting and i was just sitting there
dying
this is the same man that walked around
calling me easy to manipulate was it
true though
i think i never said that to be honest
i don't i was like look if someone said
oh you're easy to manipulate you know
you have
the door
walk out the door it is not his fault
you stayed
i don't remember
adam you say wild [ __ ]
so i would not be surprised i would not
nor would i that's why i was at that
point where i was like it made me want
to respond but it also made me go yeah i
probably actually said that
i'm like lady you met him off of tinder
and you slept with him at his parents
house like the first time you met him
oh
i thought you hooked up she stayed the
night the first time you met her
no she didn't she didn't oh i swore she
did maybe she just came back early the
next day
but the next time she came was cassville
oh
okay fine maybe maybe i was wrong maybe
i was wrong i don't adam i've met a lot
of girls through you
[Laughter]
year oh
you know what that's gross that's gross
are you and then and then and then she
says are you justifying his behavior
i'm like ma'am are you justifying yours
like
i mean yeah to be honest with you i
think hers was worse because
she
she [ __ ] slept with somebody when i
asked
i asked for space while we were dating
and she decided to go sleep with
somebody well
reagan did you guys weren't dating
it was in the air because like i kind of
put it in there i said i needed space
that was the exact same can i say didn't
you sleep with someone when he asked for
spaced lol can i say that
no i don't want you
i i was just so ticked off
okay i was just i was so mad when i
first i was like do not talk about my
brother do not ma'am that is your own
fault like get out i was so irritated i
like wanted to put a long message but i
just was like okay hold back hold back
i was like i was gonna be like you met
him i was gonna like oh my god i was
gonna put a comment reply in a video
okay like this is what i was gonna do
but i told myself not to i was gonna
reply to the comment with the video and
be like ma'am you met him off of tinder
you slept with him on the first day he
did not make him make you his girlfriend
then you stayed for a year and a half
and now you're saying and he made it
very clear to you
that he you were never going to be his
girlfriend
and now he manipulated you get
but i didn't i was like that's probably
not the best way to handle this
the amount of times i said with a
serious straight face i will never date
you again was
i literally lost count because it was
just it was just enough
bro this is what i say females like we
act like men like manipulate us but we
just don't listen we just think we can
change you
like but i'm like look ma'am
like you're a pretty girl you can get a
good amount of guys
like just go a little bit older like
guys your age are not gonna
like
like guys your age are not like
i got a good one a new one for you okay
what
so i met this girl at the bar
in december it was mid to september and
uh
she lives in dekalb so [ __ ] two and a
half hours from here hour from here or
something like that uh-huh
i think she only lives an hour i don't
think it's the calp it's something
somewhere closer but besides the point
um
she every time she we was scheduled to
do something minus so like the first two
times i had to blow her off because i
ended up going to florida the first time
and the second time i
something else happened for me i i was
busy the first two times
and then the next two she's she's kind
of been blowing very distant and blowing
them all off since because i don't i
don't know why but
my assumption being that i think she
just wants to play play the game that or
she is actually really busy with work
and i can't decide which one i think
maybe she's just not she's probably just
not that interested
she's probably not trying to
think
she's probably not playing a game she's
probably just she probably has other
guys she's more interested in
and that's kind of where i'm sitting too
so it's
i just kind of lost
lost interest in playing the game
do you want a girlfriend
no
okay
i just don't really want any of it right
now to be honest
i'm enjoying being single and alone
really what are you doing
are you in are you in
indiana i'm in chicago oh you're at home
yeah
are you and mom going crazy
well
it's been
interesting
um she helped out the other day on
something that was pretty important and
i can't really share it because it
wasn't my [ __ ] but it was
fairly important oh really yeah you're
still on live so don't
don't say anything crazy but um
no that's um that's so fun i miss the
house
to be honest with you really
well because it's only you even amelia
right
oh gosh
i think i've seen him once since we got
since we got back and then he actually
that's that's not true he left for
florida for
a week
should i go pro next year i just talked
to an agent today
i can't decide if i want to go pro or
not i could go
make decent money in this country that
sucks to live in or make like no money
in germany
but i'd still be like pro and free
housing what
what's the country
uh oh my gosh it's like this island i'd
make and it wouldn't be great money but
i'd still be making money off of youtube
so the combined the pharaoh islands
there's literally like no one on there
it's like an island close to between
iceland and the uk
and it's very cold
and there's like no one on there or i
could go to germany and
make like a quarter of the money
when would you start like the fall
it's not for a little bit
i think i'm gonna do a germany trip in
june june or july oh really i think i'd
probably pick germany that other place
seems like hell to live and
i think i'd rather just like make less
money because housing is free so i'd
only have to pay for food
yeah
i mean that's not terrible
you probably get a decent amount of your
meals paid for when you travel too so
let's see because i'd miss out it's like
five months so i'd probably miss out on
a thousand five hundred dollars less
over nine months it's like 13k though
less
i don't know decisions decisions we'll
see
i took a 20 grand pay cut just because i
didn't want to pay for housing
what
i took a 20 grand pay cut because i
didn't want to pay for housing or food
oh really
so i was like [ __ ] that i'll just live
at home it's cheaper
my mom loved that bro i miss living at
home too maybe i should come back
the end of the year mom
that she would kill me
i think i like being around my siblings
too much like i like actually enjoy
driving mom crazy and never leave
there are worse problems to have that
your kids can't make money they're just
not leaving yeah
oh my god lately i've been making
lately i've been making like no money
i'm so broke i'm so broke it's actually
really bad
guys put a donation in the chat please
oh my gosh
i i've actually raised i'm gonna do a
live show called the pre-game where i'm
gonna bring over people for a pre-game
and we're gonna do like um it's gonna be
like a podcast where we talk about
different dating topics i raised a
thousand dollars for it
so
that's pretty cool yeah you should come
on and visit me
uh i'll come in june i'll do i'll stay
for the whole month june i don't care
cool
i i work remotely so it makes my life
pretty easy i just i actually have to
work because i'm kind of like
i do a lot for
a little money
i'm underpaid very much
i thought you made a lot of money
that's what you told me before
yeah if i worked for the company in
charlotte but i don't really want to oh
you didn't take that job
yeah
i turned it down um
she's trying to renegotiate to try to
get me to go but
she really wants me down there oh you're
working for dad
yeah i think i'm gonna end up doing that
well i am doing that right now um i
still have six months left in school or
however much it is so
oh really
still gotta finish at some point here i
got offered a job the other day making
tick tocks like 20 hours a week for like
a decent money for like a part-time job
but
if i did that i like don't think i could
do youtube as much
and i think i'm just going to wait
what
would we have to do
no no no it's like under theirs but
it's like on their page but i just don't
i don't think i have time
to do it without doing less on youtube
so i think i'm i think i'm going to turn
it down and just take a risk with this
podcast that's what i'm leaning towards
because i think it's going to be pretty
good like with the equipment i'm getting
and stuff
so i guess we'll see
yeah
let's see that'll be interesting
yeah and then but if that takes off like
i don't know i might even stay in london
i get a visa here for three years so
we'll see
we will see
yeah
don't you have visa to leave the country
no as an american you can visit
somewhere for up to six months at least
the uk i don't know what it is
but you could like literally be here for
six months and they wouldn't
interesting
does the uk require
the coven
to
pass and all that um i think you
need to test within a certain amount of
time
but you got i accidentally took your
covet thing remember like
yeah you brought it back
yeah my bad
my bad
i don't know where it is but yeah i
think you need to get a covid test
either way but
i don't know that you get
you have to do one less thing if you
have the vaccine so i don't know
um
yeah
mother just responded to a text message
dan's garage should i be worried
are they getting a divorce
dan's garage
oh my gosh
they're currently in breckenridge skiing
at the moment oh really
yeah
yeah apparently they have some of their
friends up there and apparently two of
them have altitude sickness already so
that's fun
huh
that was fun
yeah i was actually just there with my
friends from florida and literally
everybody but you got to do sickness and
i was like you guys came from zero to
1200 feet and you didn't drink any water
people always think they can avoid it
they always think they can avoid it
no it's so bad and one of them colby we
were dude i was scared that we were
gonna have to take him to the hospital
because
he
the dude just literally didn't take care
of himself like the first night he we
got there he didn't drink enough water
which i already predicted off the start
and then he all he did was smoke weed
and drink the first night and i was like
you're gonna be [ __ ] off your ass
first thing in the morning we go we get
up we're all ready to go skiing and he
we get in the car and he's like i don't
feel great i was like not surprising do
you want to stay here he's like no no
i'll be good to ski we literally make it
down like half a run and he's sitting
puking on the side of the hill i was
like good thing i brought this can of
oxygen because you're gonna [ __ ] die
if we don't
and then literally i gave him a can of
oxygen resets that he gets his breath
back he's like all right i'm going home
like yeah no kidding
no surprise there
he goes home sleeps for the entire day
and then like we make these
um the girls that came with us made some
[ __ ] delicious dinners
like holy [ __ ]
thank you sandy oh my god she was a good
cook um
and then so he didn't he was like i
can't really eat i don't feel great
turns out he's been eating [ __ ] ice
cream sandwiches and like junk food all
day so it was like no surprise you still
feel like [ __ ] after a day of not
taking care of yourself in the mountains
it just kept getting worse i was like oh
my god no well my one friend literally
got so much altitude sickness that she
thought she was dying me to take her to
the hospital it was
oh my god did you see what kim just or
kanye just posted about kim
he put up his kids are on tick tock
kanye post since this is my first
divorce i need to know what should i do
about my daughter being put on tick tock
against my will
why does he just put this [ __ ] in the
public
he's so funny
okay i should probably
what
i found that kanye for president hat the
other day i don't know where i got it
from but it was in my room
now i have a cool cadre for president
sounds like something you would have
okay i'm gonna finish this video though
i need to finish this video i feel bad
my audience has been like listening to
me talk to you for 20 minutes
i think they think you're
i think they think you're very funny and
i do think they enjoyed that but
i think i need to finish this because i
did title it that i'm reacting to the
roommates so i think when people click
they expect me to
go
okay go to sleep brother
sister miss you
bye
bro i'm sorry
it made me so mad this girl comments on
my tick tock i'm like get that f out of
here lady let me talk about how much i
love my brothers without you commenting
get out get out okay that's not helpful
for society in the long run you painting
a negative picture of life just to make
money yeah they do it
and so in a content creator's space a
lot of the guys the difference is that
music subconsciously educates you
but a lot of people don't realize their
content is explicitly educating other
people people are going here to learn
about the truth and if you're going to
teach someone the truth you have to
teach them the good and the bad the bad
and the ugly yeah i think again place is
like fresh and fit that's right can't
just only show the ugly of life same
with the women like the feminists the
extreme feminists there's enough
bad things men have done in society to
paint men to be the worst species to
ever walk the face of the earth there is
enough
if you want to find all those contents
and i've always uh
likened it to
um in 2011
um
when the world trade center got crashed
and when the buildings got crashed
um my name is hafiz hafiz means one of
memorizes the koran at that time i was i
had a lot of muslim friends
and i remember when that happened
all the muslim guys after that one event
everybody they like they would they had
to leave school some of the guys had the
least be talking about the interview go
to school okay i get it some people use
clickbait for a week people were some
people were randomly using new york
i left new york at that time i was
actually in i was actually in atlanta at
this time but imagine if i was in new
york it was only escalated my friends in
new york were telling me like yo like
some people they literally did not go to
school for the entire month because they
knew like there was ireland even in even
in toronto even in toronto that happened
and that was canada yeah yeah and so i
so at that moment i realized that if if
all if all you see because most people
don't especially around the country
don't really meet or interact with
muslims if all you saw from a muslim is
him blowing up a building
now every time you see them you're gonna
have that correlation to think
terrorist criminal blow up the building
i remember i had so many people would
tell me like
that you know
as a muslim you couldn't pray if you had
to pray
in the airport
you couldn't pray anymore there was a
time where you could go maybe go into
the corner and pray at the airport you
could not pray in the airport if you
were a muslim from 2001 probably until
even now like it's
because people would see you
praying
a lot more you know they're like yeah
i'm not getting on the plane with them
because
that's spot on yeah i've been telling my
followers and i think this is just
important for people
to do is if what you're viewing on
social media is making you feel worse
then you have to stop looking at it
right because you end up in social media
also caters to what you click on so if
you're like okay this was kind of
interesting and it's this click-baity
video that makes your outlook of the
world more negative it's just going to
keep showing you those things because
you press on them and
so you have to think about how you want
your life to be right and probably
surrounding yourself with resentful
people whether or not you're in the like
red pill community or on the like way
over on the left if it's making you
resentful especially towards like well
towards anybody but blah blah blah
oh this is like a tiring conversation to
listen to because it's not talking about
anything important yes there's internet
trolls okay
where's the opposite sex too whom you're
going to have a relationship going to
have to have a relationship with if you
want to have a family maybe you
shouldn't be watching content that makes
you resentful and then potentially stops
you from having a relationship and a
family like maybe watch something more
positive
or like it's kind it's important right
especially for kids or teenagers who get
into it early or like young people
yeah
no and especially when you think about
how many people nowadays are being
shaped by the internet
you know with with the lockdown some
people for the past two years in certain
cities they've they've never they've
never been outside you know and so be
for that very reason now yeah they're
whole okay
um i need i feel like rolo is going to
destroy these people i'm not even gonna
lie to you um i'm
okay where does he start with the video
reaction there we go
um
in like
no it's not pre-recorded conditions so
i'm going to show you this this is the
uh the the first stream here and this is
huffy's and michaela on the
roommates podcast there it is
you you you've you've gotten really deep
into the men's space and the men's
dating space with like even the some of
the crazy red pill content and all types
of
foolishness that goes on about in that
space what
how did you find that and like what has
been your experience seeing it learning
it hearing about it all that stuff
all right let me uh let's let's even
just stop it right there
what did i just say okay thank you so
much for the donation
you guys already know this is going
towards
my youtube channel the show i'm gonna do
it's gonna be called the pre-game why
because the pre-game is better than the
party you have better conversations at
the pre-game i'm gonna have hot girls
athletes from my college have different
conversations about
dating dynamics um my goal is a thousand
dollars i know that's a big goal but
it's gonna cover four more microphones
and another sound board to hook them up
okay
um i'm at about a hundred
i think this puts me at 160 or 180 i
can't remember which but thank you
about
e-celebrities pretending to know
something about the manosphere
this is hafiz sort of putting the ball
the t on the on the t so she can hit off
the t you know t-ball that's where this
is going
you're you've been you've been an expert
at this for a while you've you've been
sort of intimately aware of the
manosphere for a long time so tell us
how what's your what's your opinion of
all of this
uh okay the red pill space are you
talking about rolo yeah oh yeah yeah
like all those all that
content over there because i feel like
i think you were talking about
especially in the interview how you you
were researching it and you were
learning about it and you were curious
about it i was just curious like how did
you
i think it makes i have an idea of how
you got there but i'm curious to like
you know
how did you really get there and then
like what is some of like your your your
thought process about just some of that
type of content
for someone who has been doing a lot of
research quote unquote ten dollars thank
you
oh my gosh i i can't remember i think
i'm at one
i think i'm at 170 now i could be off by
like 10 or 20 bucks but i'm thinking
about 170 now thank you thank you thank
you thank you
a lot of research
she certainly didn't know who i was
prior to the interview that we had this
is what i say as women as women you need
to watch a lot of the content before you
make an assumption about it
it's not fun when you first watch it
you're like oh my god everyone's a hoe
because that's that's what it sounds
like because that's like a lot of it i'm
not even going to lie to you it's like
rulo's like
ho ho ho fresh and better like ho ho ho
but there's more to it it's not it's not
that simple but
he's right you have to watch a lot of
the content before you make a conclusion
about it and it's unfortunate because it
kind of takes a while to do that
i can show that to you here in just a
moment but again setting her up as some
sort of preeminent authority on the
manosphere okay well i think
specifically for royal tomasi i'd heard
of the rational mail i think i heard
about it in high school interesting yeah
i i think that was the first time i
heard it mentioned so i and i just heard
you know certain people bring it up you
know whenever and i was like okay well
that's interesting if he's doing the
same i didn't know very much about him i
was like if he's doing the same thing
though all right this is uh this is uh
let's just say miss troop
maybe it's a misunderstanding
thank you sir thank you we're at 172 of
the a thousand dollar goal i know it's a
big goal but i already told you guys
this podcast is going to be fire
she's saying that she had first heard of
my work of my book i guess in high
school
all right
so let's let's turn back the clock here
for one moment uh michaela is uh as of
january this year she is 30 years old
the book came out
was published october 1st 2013.
if that's the case she would have
already been out of high school
and or at least a senior in high school
at that time
when that was when that came out so you
know we're looking at what is to so
nine years about nine years
so subtract nine years from where she's
at right now and maybe she's 18 or 19.
so i and again i don't know the
logistics actually i should i could
actually i could uh pair that all the
way back down so as far as i know she's
already out of high school there is no
there is no rational male book available
at the time that she's a
maybe it came oh no actually it didn't
because she would have been a senior and
out of high school by that time
because it would have been october of
first and as far as we just got the date
confused why are we focusing on this i
don't care as i know
graduation from most high schools is
right around like the end of may maybe
the beginning of june
so that is i'm not saying that's a lie
but i'm saying that's kind of doubtful
if not stretching the truth
like robert glover is doing
yes
but that was kind of my thinking i was
like if he's doing that kind of
that kind of thing like maybe that'd be
an interesting podcast so i think it was
just like naivety
so i hadn't actually like sat down i
don't actually really watch podcasts i
have a podcast but i don't really watch
podcasts
so i guess you didn't do any research on
all of this
presuming that i was going to be like dr
robert glover which who by the way has
ducked most of the interviews that i've
ever tried to do with him let's just put
that one out there but
um so you're not the preeminent expert
on the manosphere then i take it
uh
or listen to podcasts so i think it may
be just naivety yeah and it was like i
thought it was kind of the same thing i
was like oh if you're teaching men to
take more responsibility and
just
i like i understand like the hatred
towards men that's kind of going on on
the left i was like well if it's not
that and you're
then that's good but i i think i just
didn't do my research properly
so in that case in other words
you didn't do your research the research
that hafiz just one minute ago said that
you had done
right am i am i wrong
please feel free to correct me anybody
wants jacob fees was just trying to
start a conversation to be honest like i
think he was just like trying to ask a
question and like get the conversation
so correct me i'm all ears at this point
so clearly
there had to have been some reason
why you wanted me to come on the show
we'll talk about that here a little bit
later on in this show
but clearly you are not an expert or any
kind of authority
that hafiz would like you to would like
to make you out to be
and would you consider me an expert on
the manosphere
i won't get offended either way i've
watched a lot of manosphere content but
i've never read his book so i'd probably
say no you presume that my messaging is
going to be like dr robert glover right
and um
again i have uh i've attempted to do
interviews or or table or panel talks i
can remember with myself rich cooper dr
sean smith and i think it was and and dr
robert glover and we're supposed to have
this conversation about hypergamy and
nobody wanted to have a nobody wanted to
talk about it well i too is credit at
least sean smith did
and so after a while it's like when
communications break down i don't know
how to put this mac i'm gonna be i'm
gonna i'm gonna try to be respectful
i see your comments you've called on my
show a couple times
you come off as more emotional than rolo
you do
i'm sorry i'm sorry
respectfully i appreciate the support
but like
this this isn't emotional
to me anyways
like this does not seem like he's
emotional
and nobody wants to talk about it i can
only presume
that you don't really have much of an
argument
so that's you know you want to know
where i'm at with dr robert i don't have
anything personal again someone just
saying you know if you want to talk
about it i'm here but it doesn't seem
like there's ever going to be any kind
of conversation about anything
because once again it goes against this
uh emotionalism versus empiricism what
feels good what tastes good
and i don't
really
doesn't taste good it doesn't taste very
good
accurate that is so true
and that's what i always say it's not a
fun reality
he just sticks you with the facts so
when what time do i have to leave for
practice
you build her up to be this authority
which she is not and again like i've
said this before she's 30 going on 12
especially when it comes to this kind of
you know this kind of material but we
still look to her as if she's in some
way
some
some kind of authority or she has some
sort of doctorate degree in the
manosphere
and it's simply not true now the other
thing i wanted to point out here as well
as another thing that is a common error
that not just michaela makes but also
uh matt wall i'd say matt walsh most of
the trad cons make because they love
that side of the manosphere where it's
like well you know to
if you want to be a better man if you
want to be a better you know you have to
men must become they love that when i
say men must be women they don't like
they don't like women just are but when
i say
women just are and men must become they
latch on to men must become when i say
women just are they're like what's he
talking about that doesn't sound right
that doesn't taste good but we love what
what does taste good is men must become
men must take more responsibility they
must find a way to the manhood medal and
the way to do that
take more responsibility
even though you don't have that's always
the the the panacea for all
you know for the crisis of masculinity
for the lost boys for you name name the
name the malady of you know contemporary
masculinity today
like oh we have such a low enrollment
rate in uh in our major universities
right now oh more and more men are being
forced out of the workplace because
their jobs are being like turned you
know and to be honest it doesn't really
matter if he's emotional or not now that
i think about it like what matters is he
right or is he wrong like that's the
only thing that matters like if we're
being honest done by robots or they're
being forced out of like you know
textile industry or whatever it is like
what a steal or whatever it is that men
traditionally do right
they're construction workers they work
in raw sewage they're electricians they
have a trade they've got all this other
stuff
but
when they're forced out of that or they
can't
find a you know a
suitable mate or they can't become a
suitable mate as a result of the fact of
the choices that they've made because
women decide that they'd only want to
get with the best of the best right and
the best of the best is somebody who is
their equal you know educational equal
their
their financial equal we can talk about
all that stuff like oh name the malady
name the issue right now and you know
what the most common answer is going to
be well men just need to take more
responsibility so when i say men must
become or when rich cooper says chase
excellence or when rich says you know
become the best version of yourself that
you can be right
it's not it's what they what they fail
to understand
is
rich and myself and anybody else who's
sort of on at least in the rule zero
family and certainly you know in the
extended family and also and
i would say even in the greater whole of
the manosphere right now when we talk
about sort of male improvement that we
are in some way saying
you know man up taking responsibility
come back to the plantation come in
marry this you know man up and marry
these these [ __ ] right no one's saying
that
when we talk about male improvement we
try to keep them i try to keep the gun
out of your mouth and the noose off your
neck
it's because i care about the guys
when these guys talk about it it's
because they want you to be a more
suitable you want to build a better beta
they want you to be more suitable
because
your your problems as a man are
affecting women women most affected
that's the whole and i know that's a
meme now on twitter but that's why
and she repeats that right here well you
know if it's all about you know men
taking responsibility i'm all for it i'm
sure you are
because that benefits women
again men are just an accessory you are
a draft animal or you are breeding stock
and in most cases you're
most likely you're just a draft animal
and i know that sounds negative and oh
it doesn't sound happy and what's the
where's the positivity in that i am
simply holding up a mirror i am i just
work here right
and i can point to
case after case and research after
research and data set after data set and
i can show you how women want to be with
a guy who is sort of economically
attractive okay well does that make us
all gold diggers no we're not all gold
diggers well that's the problem is when
you see those data sets that's
the connection most people make
it's not about this you know
well i think women are attracted to men
that are driven
yeah like i i think that's
am i misinterpreting what he's saying
like i think he's just saying women tend
to like the most driven
man
that they can get right
love
or whatever you know it's not about this
ideal
and men would love it to be too this
idealized you know titanic in rose and
jack and you know the
frozen death as he goes to the bottom of
the ocean kind of love that's not what
it's about no bro oh my god i i said
this on my twitter the other day i was
such a buzzkill at like 12. i swear to
god because i hated the titanic movie
when i was 12
i was out there
i was up there saying
there is no way that was like this is
the worst movie ever everyone said this
was so good there is no way that she was
in love with that guy she met him for
three days three days she was in lust
unless like i was like 12 saying this
this is how i knew i was weird because
all the other girls were like this is a
great movie and same with the notebook i
was
i was i saw that movie and i said bro
she's cheating
bring this [ __ ] to the streets
no it's about he needs to make 58 more
money than i do to be economically
attractive to be my equal
that's what it's about
and so what do we tell men
you need to be more responsible you need
you need to just man up you need to you
know what yeah men no i would tell women
like
there's only so many men that make 58
more money than you right now for me
it'd be pretty easy i'm pretty broke
enrollment rate in college is only 40
percent yo send a donation you already
know you know what i'm gonna do the
pregame i know i keep talking about this
but send donations for the pregame which
is a podcast i'm gonna do out of my
apartment i live right next to campus
it's gonna be college girls athletes
whatever we're all gonna have
conversations about dating dynamics and
the reason i'm asking for donations for
it is because i want to raise a thousand
dollars so right now i have four
microphones i need four more and another
sound board to hook them up
and i'm at i'm at like 170 in terms of
like how much money i've raised well hmm
well that's that's terrible but uh okay
let's uh let's start creating um
initiatives in a title nine program or
like uh giving these guys pell grants or
you know financial aid for men to go to
college that doesn't happen there's
plenty of those those uh those
scholarships and those grants and that's
true i don't know why as women i mean
it's kind of offensive when they have
all these special programs for us
and not men
like
i don't know we don't need it
we're smart
all that college money and
everything else for women who want to
get into stem and coding and any like
traditional email space we're happy to
put them there but you say hey men we
need to put you you know when it looks
like the enrollment rates are in the in
the toilet right now we really need to
get you in it's not oh let's help it's
you need to get off your ass and and
enroll or else no
and be suitable enough
in the future for some woman to want to
have anything to do with you
that's where that responsibility hustle
comes in and i think i me i'm sorry i
had to like highlight that so
specifically but i am sick to death of
hearing that
because that's always a it's the go-to
answer it sounds truthy it's that
aphorism right now and do men need to
take responsibility yeah sure they do
but you know what they can't take
responsibility and they can't maintain
that responsibility if they don't have
the authority to do so and when i bring
that up on
you uh yeah that's true
that's 100 true yeah you are here or you
name the show that i go on i'm sure i
will mention this on the patrick bet
david show on tuesday i guarantee you i
will
men do not have the authority to affect
that responsibility that we
magically think is going to like secure
all this crisis of masculinity
what has been like after you know
the conversation after doing more
research what are some of the things
that you you've come to realize
about some of that space i'm just
curious how you process it
i think that
okay
she just said
i haven't done any research she just
said
i have been naive about this whole thing
that look on her face right there is a
look of confusion for like
the serious like red pill depending on
the person but some of those people are
angry like really angry like usually
when i this part made me so mad because
i was like
any movement there's going to be angry
people like who cares have a
conversation with someone and i'll bring
like left-wing people on the podcast too
and generally speaking i can have a
conversation with anybody and
generally speaking we leave feeling like
okay that was a reasonable conversation
and with
rolo in particular it was like
nothing about that felt good we didn't
leave on the same level at all
uh and
i think some of those people are there's
some like anger towards women going on
and that's the criticism
all right
if you did left
if you left the conversation and you
didn't feel good about any of that
i succeeded
comfort the afflicted and afflict the
comfortable
that's my goal right now especially when
it comes to the work and the talk that i
do
when it comes to my books
it's basically just saying yeah i lost
the debate
she did i'm sorry michaela i love your
dad your dad changed my life i swear to
god he convinced me to stop drinking he
convinced me to make better decisions
but
um yeah you lost that debate i'm just
i'm just keeping it a buck with you
licked the comfortable
comfort the afflicted
i'm about to order dinner what should i
order
i'm gonna order nando's and that's where
we're at right now of course it didn't
taste good of course it didn't leave a
good you know feeling at the end of that
is that what your point was
because i can tell you right now that's
not what your point was and we're gonna
we're gonna we're gonna part we're gonna
tease that one out here in just a second
but that wasn't your point that was
certainly not the purpose of the of
of our our talk
and i have a much clearer perspective of
all that at this point so let's keep
going here but again
was that supposed to be the goal to feel
good about everything afterwards no i
don't care if you feel good or bad after
my shows i care that you're educated i
care that you have the data i care that
you have the tools
to build a better life and i hope that
can make you feel good absolutely
i hope that you can build a better
lifestyle i hope you can chase
excellence i hope you can date women i
hope you can at least understand
that yeah our women are the enemy no
women are not the enemy but you still
have to understand women's nature it's
just like 48 laws of power
it's like it's just women always want to
get the next best thing
like
sad as that is like women are always
everyone's gonna try to get the best
deal that they can i think men and women
alike but men are more willing to like
settle and not leave if things like if
it's good enough but women are like let
me
let me go
okay i just ordered dinner
evil book no it's not an evil book you
need to know those laws does that mean
you're going to use all of those laws
and you know be a sinister
dark triad fiend
machiavellian fiend because you know no
you but you it behooves you to know
those things so that you know what to
expect from people my dog too loud she's
kind of snoring
so that you know when those of those
laws are being used against you
so yeah good i hope i didn't leave a
good taste in your mouth michaela
isn't a red pill community gets too it's
like why do you hate women but like
and and initially i thought that was
kind of a misrepresentation in the media
like everything else is a
misrepresentation but
i think that there are some red-pilled
people that really don't like women you
can see by like you can see it pretty
clearly yeah and it's not for the
betterment like
teaching people
that all women are a certain way or all
men are a certain way i think men are
less willing to settle
i don't think women would be as
overweight as they are if that were true
uh
i don't think that that's
going to actually make people make
things better make people get along
better yeah yeah
all right
once again
we're leaning into binary extremes here
i've how many times have i said you know
we live in the tldr generation
uh quick hit give me another info bite
as i drive through the drive-through at
mcdonald's and throw it in my mouth i've
gotta i've got places to go thank you
very much thank you i got things to do
that's
not what the red pill is about
it takes time it takes time to
understand it it seems like i will say
this again i have tried to reinforce
this quote i will probably put it in a
in a book at some point it's not in any
book but the
language of empiricism the language of
reason the language of data the language
of statistics the language of
hard objective truth
will always sound angry to believers to
uh emotionalists to people who want to
feel good at the end of the conversation
to people who think that happiness is a
sustainable goal state that they can
perpetuate for most of their lives no
you can't you're not supposed to
it is not the human condition see this
is why rolo does not come off as likable
i'm not even gonna lie
sorry sorry i just
he's he's he's correct
he's correct i think
i was half ordering chicken so i'm not
gonna lie to you edition
and so when we talk about oh well they
say you know all women are like this are
all women men are like that well okay
we can also look so we have to have to
understand like you're talking about in
generalities and you
everything it becomes a lot easier to
swallow if you just like
understand things that like they're
talking in general
it's not every single little thing
bounce that out as i've said before you
can be your that against the lie of
individuation you can yes our people
these you know unique wonderful beings
sure they can be there there's no one
like you there's no one like you there's
no one like you it's like
everything is you take away consequences
you take away consequences from women
what do they do they're more hypergamous
because there's no consequence for being
hypergamous
you bring in consequences they become
less hypergamous and they realize what
they can actually get
everything
yeah everything in life is about
consequences and if people have
consequences
and there you are an original creation
right i mean you're an original
evolution whatever it is
but there's commonalities okay
there are commonalities men are men and
women are different
and we have we are different but we are
common amongst our
the way that the machine is built
and that's what we focus on in the red
pill that's what we focus on in the
manner sphere we don't say oh well you
know everyone it's not this
deterministic this horribly you know
inviolable determinism
we we
we talk about this all the time yes
there are things in your upbringing
there are things in your personality
there are things in your ethnicity and
you're certainly in your gender
certainly in your the way that you were
raised certainly where you were raised
there there's a million different
variables and factors but there are
commonalities
amongst the
machinery
and that's what we talk about we don't
go oh all women are the same or all men
are the same we don't no one if there is
some right and that's that's what you
have to understand the red pill it
doesn't mean every single person is the
same it just means like there are things
that women do in general like women tend
to be more hypergamous they want to get
every everyone wants to get the best
deal they can women are just more
willing to wait out and men are more
willing to be like you know what
that's that's my good enough women women
are not
somebody in the in the manosphere in the
red pill community right now who is
saying that you send them to me
okay
please do
because that is
a [ __ ] 101
that is a that is a repeated lie that i
keep hearing from people who want to
pick and pull like i said the parts of
the red pill that they like and the
parts that they don't
no that makes sense i
think you know my experience in the
men's space i've been i've been just
i've i watch everybody i i try to read
almost everything you know and you know
there's there's good and bad everywhere
and there's extreme
you know red pill you believe that i
watch everything i read everything
it's extreme all this stuff and i don't
i don't want to paint everybody in the
same light
but to me the most fascinating thing is
like if you were to pick like uh i would
i would really describe it as like uh
there's no consequences for my first
wife she ended up putting a woman in the
hospital she hadn't been punished before
that yeah like
everything like this is i look at the
light i look at life through the lens of
consequences i
think when you take consequences from
people men and women people tend to do
the wrong thing more
so
yeah
that's why
i think free range and strict parenting
works in like different ways because if
it's free-range parenting like
kids kind of suffer consequences on
their own because their parents like
don't barrel them out
but if you're strict there's also like
consequences okay
the enemy of a red pill guy
is a it's like a left-wing feminist
that's like his arch rifle yeah yeah
yeah but if you let a left-wing feminist
tell you about men
and what men
what they're going to do is they're
going to compare the red pill to
feminism that's that's this is another
common thing
uh they think that they're being clever
here they think this is novel but this
argument has been brought up
really is like i had a hard time
watching this because i was like this is
just not
a good argument
i think the first time i've heard i
heard this was right around 2009 2010
and it was primarily directed at mras
men's rights activists or movements
whatever
um at that time and a lot of people were
comparing the mras to
feminists
and it kind of it kind of it kind of
went in vogue and out of vogue for a
little while it's in vogue right now
because it's again it's truthy and it
sounds like they know it sounds
deductive right it sounds like well
it's the same thing when it comes when i
say you know what's good for the goose
is good for the gander if there's a
it's blank slate thinking but it's also
sort of this um
like
black and white thinking it's it's
binary thinking that if they're if red
pill is this way then feminists are like
this and so that's the they're they're
just male feminists right or they're
just male meninists and feminists are
these right and so they think that
there's some sort of like um
yin and yang thing going on in all of
this because again they can't
they can't conceive
a reality
where
i'm about to get cancelled
i've never been canceled before this
would be so exciting oh wait no i have i
was cancelled once
oh that would be that'd be kind of fun
there is just this one individual unique
faction and there's another one over it
always has to be if there's an if
there's an action there has to be an
equal and opposite reaction that karma
right it's got you know what comes
around goes around no sometimes what
goes around just [ __ ] goes around
that's that's the truth of it when
people say oh what about the pendulum do
you think that the pendulum is going to
swing back to the 195 when when are we
going to uh no and that's what that's
what i always say on the channel like
we can't undo where we're at like we're
already where we're at so it's kind of
like what what do we do now solve this
um
the the the gynocentric social order
problem rollo when will the pendulum
swing back it won't
because we have to go forward there
ain't no going backward yeah you can
certainly use that our you know this
idealistic
golden era of
manhood back in the day and use that as
sort of a model going forward but you
are not there is no as far as i know
there ain't no time machine you can jump
in and go back to to 1950. you there
there's you're not going to do that you
can only go forward but they suffer from
the same
malady
as guys who you know
maybe well-meaning want to go you know
swing the pendulum back to men
that's not going to happen you have to
change you have to find some way to
force your
retake authority first of all
but to
affect your will upon the world
and that's really what you're asking me
not about the some pendulum stupid
pendulum hoping that you're going to be
you know good to go on the backswing
no you have to make an effort you have
to actually go and do something
and
that requires you to have this
fundamental idea that that first of all
that that's possible and then second of
all it is not about like a yin and a
yang a balance this a balance that the
pendulum swings one way and swings the
other way no no it doesn't we're in
uncharted waters my friends
we have never done this before in the
history of humanity we have never had
the the access to information the way
that we do right now but we still have
this old order thinking that says well
if there are
if there are plus people there must be
minus people right there must be some
sort of equilibrium no there doesn't
have to be because men and women are not
blank slates we are different
so the imperatives and the
strategies and the the the
the agendas of feminists
does not have to be the
inversion
of what red pill guys are about but
that's the way believers think because
it feels good well that's that that
explains it doesn't it
do to women and how men behave and what
men are like
and you were to change the word man with
woman yeah it sounds exactly exactly
it's exactly the same sex
is good for the game
one of the one of the advantages of like
this whole conversation is just saying
nothing
like nothing
what we did was in the year 2019 we went
on tour with one of my mentors who's
actually a female dating coach oh good
um besides matthew huss he's like the
largest female dating coach in the world
what's his name stefan labossiere okay
yeah i'll show your social media he has
like five million followers around the
social media he's cool really really
rough perspective he's a very positive
person
and so uh so stefan you know he's this
rock star i was on tour and i was a
video guy so i wasn't teaching i wasn't
lecturing i was just
recording and observing
and then you would see some of these
women the the the ones who've been hurt
the ones who who have this very dogmatic
belief you see them share it and you see
them express their their hurt and their
anger towards men and
and what happens is when you
when you get hurt
all of a sudden you look yeah i have
been going on for like three hours
please send a donation por favor like
please pretty please
please
it's going towards the podcast you
already know look for validation for
your hurt so now
when you see somebody do something
right you don't notice it but when you
see someone do something wrong you
notice it so for example they can see 50
guys
open their doors for their wife
they won't notice that but they see one
guy yelling and screaming at his wife
they notice that it and it reinforces
their beliefs yeah why would they notice
that
why would and i love how like okay why
is that the examples he's giving right
here well i opened the door for my wife
i love my wife very much oh wait they
don't see that i'm good i don't know
they kind of do because my most popular
tweet of 2021 the most the most
engagement i got in 2021 was on my
anniversary on july 20th i tweeted out
one simple sentence
and that was today uh uh on this day 25
years ago i married my wife and that was
it and everyone was too happy or too sad
about that but it wasn't just one or the
other it was both
and so they were looking at both sides
of it and so i had i had you know people
going hey congratulations all right good
for you yeah yay gay marriage and then i
had other guys going oh man don't you
realize you're uh living on borrowed
time she could take half of your stuff
rolo oh are you endorsing marriage
and so i get it from both sides i
understand that
but the problem here is that this is
founded in there the reason why he comes
to these conclusions or the reason why
he uses these examples here
is because he exceeds he's looking and
he's finding what he expects to find
he's expecting people who are going to
lose their [ __ ] because of a guy who uh
was yelling at
a woman and you'll notice it also
couches this in um again a female
primary agenda right oh you should open
the door for your wife or your
girlfriend or
a woman but you shouldn't
yell at that woman
those are the examples he could use any
any example
to to reinforce the idea and and i agree
with this is that we tend to as human
beings we tend to lock onto things are
negative experiences we tend to remember
pain more than we do pleasure
because when we do we learn that because
it's a survival instinct that's exactly
she's going to fumble around and go i
think it's an evolutionary thing
now she'll talk about that here in just
a second but i mean she's not wrong she
just kind of fumbles into it
but it's true we tend to focus fixate
primarily on negative painful
experiences because we don't want to
repeat those that's why and so that's
why we get ptsd right that's why we we
fixate on on negativity that's why we
get depressed that's why we get uh upset
about things that remind us of bad
memories yeah of course yeah we do oh my
god i don't have practice tonight
oh that's dope i should go work out
i'll buy the game in the morning
i probably won't i should have went
earlier today i totally thought i'd
practice
that and that's simply the way that the
machine works again one more thing you
know
it fascinates me that just like
not even three minutes ago
we're complaining that the red pill
focuses too much on uh this um this you
know horribly deterministic
um
philosophy or or this the these this
principle of uh we you know what is it
men and women are are all like this
but they're ex they're engaging in
exactly that same kind of thinking right
here well all of them we all do these
things we all you know fixate on on this
negativity we all fixate on the the
painful experiences because we don't
want to repeat them right like i said
it's a survival instinct okay that's
part of the machine
if we were all different if we were
why would you even be having this
conversation if we didn't all have at
least some sort of commonality
to
want to avoid pain and be attracted to
pleasure that's part of the machine
that's how we evolved that sounds an
awful lot like a commonality that we
have as human beings but i thought we
were all special little snowflakes
i thought we were supposed to say
everybody yeah and i think the
comparison he's making sorry i'm very
hungry so i'm very excited for this food
um
that's that's what as women we listen to
red pill and we're like what i'm not
like that
i didn't go crazy
i didn't do this this and this but
he's talking about women in general in
general there's always exceptions to
every rule
so
yeah cause when you first listen to it
you think you're like what the i'm not a
gold digger but i think we're
evolutionarily designed to be attracted
to hard-working men and ambitious men
that can take care of us to be honest
but i think there's a difference between
that being a gold digger because i don't
think men win the lottery and are
automatically like attractive i think
it's like but being a ceo that makes you
more attractive because of the behaviors
so but he's the same because right now
you're saying everybody's this name
and so i would notice i'll be like dang
it and i we would try to talk to the
women be like yo there's there's so much
more to men than what the media paints
it and you try to open their eyes and
they're stuck oh my god
you're gonna get blocked who keeps
making fake accounts stop it
that's not me in the chat stop they're
not listening to you they're stuck in
their ways and then you know doing what
we're doing for men you see that you're
like you're just like her
these women that we would meet on tour
who were hurt who were bitter who were
nihilistic who were bet on all men are
like this and this is how they are
they're here to hurt women and screw you
over like
and you see these guys like that
and
i would like to see who these guys are
because that has not been my experience
working with guys particularly
at you know events like the one i just
did at rebel capitalist or the ones that
i do out in miami or
people who just come and shake my hands
and have sent you know hand me
a handwritten letter saying thank you
for saving my son's lives
thank you for helping us out thank you
you know you again you're maybe you're
maybe you're right maybe we do fixate
primarily on the negative well it's not
roll over it's not okay
it's probably not the people you've met
in person everyone i've met in person
from the red pill for like the most part
except i can think of one that was not
very nice but for the most part it's
like very nice to be honest
but but here's here's the problem it's
like
when i post a video
and i'm constantly told that i'm about
to hit the wall and i'm a five and all
this stuff all day i get it you know
i probably they're not wrong
but it's like
how often do you want to just be like
told this over and over again it's like
okay i get it
and sometimes the comment section is
just like
this so pessimistic all the time like
it can be tiring like sometimes i get
really really tired of red pill content
because it's been my experience that has
been overwhelmingly positive
that my work has been
instrumental in changing men's lives for
the positive for
having them cancel their date with
suicide
i can you if you want me to show you the
testimonials i'm happy to show them to
you because i have i have the receipts
so
when we say oh well they're all hurt and
blah blah blah okay great what are you
doing to keep the news off their necks
what are you doing to change their minds
even if that's true and i don't
necessarily believe it's all generally
true that every guy that goes to seek
them out is in some way like damaged
goods
and
it's absolutely ridic and then again of
course
those are the guys
he's just simply like confirming his own
bs which is those are the same guys who
would be seeking this out in the first
place aren't they the negative people
that you constantly see all the time
so would that bias would that implicit
bias not also apply to the guys who you
seem to think are all just hurting deep
inside
again it's this emotion okay and i
should point this out
in no uncertain terms that everything
that's come out of their mouths up to
this point has been just about emotion
well what they're hurt individuals
no they're educated when you educate a
man he he ceases to become a suitable
slave
when you and i'm i'm uh quoting uh uh
what is it uh douglas uh
god damn it
i'm stealing a quote sorry my bad
somebody will get give it back to me um
but uh
when you educate a guy i think it was ed
ed lattimore once said i wasn't i wasn't
doing an
interview one time with ed lattimore and
we were talking about
um just give you an example okay i was
just thinking of like examples of how
the red pill can sometimes be tiring
um an introverted girl will give you
memories that last a lifetime an
extroverted girl will give you stds that
last a lifetime this is a tweet from
revolino
and i'm like damn
i like to chit chat oh jesus
i've never had like i've never
had anything
like
an std or anything i'm very careful with
that stuff so
i'm like what the [ __ ]
sir like i'm sorry i'm friendly but like
you have to understand who they're
talking about with girls that like have
to be the center of attention in every
room that are like flirting with
everybody like
that's who they're talking about
i think
anyways
work in my work as well and he says this
is like giving uh this is like teaching
slaves to read
and that's the difference here
so yes i would
i would not doubt one bit that the women
that matt hussey and this other guy that
he's talking about right here
are all very
distraught because they
are the
products of the choices and the
decisions that they've made the women
that go to see matthew that lift up matt
hussey and and probably this guy too i'm
not familiar with the guy he just
mentioned but if matt hussey is the is
the sort of template for that guy the
women who go to see matt hussey
the women who are who just lift up first
of all matt hussey's like no homo but
he's a pretty good looking guy and he
has successfully been a female dating
coach for a long time primarily because
what he tells or what he convinces women
is like don't worry girls don't worry
gals i'm going to go and teach the guys
to be better betas and to so they'll be
more suitable for you and once they get
their [ __ ] together then i'll bring them
to you and then finally you'll have the
right guy
so you've been waiting you're freezing
your
egg um
yeah maybe some i've not watched matthew
hussey in a long time but like
i would say he
he's very good at like boundaries
i would say it's like a good thing that
he does but a lot of the stuff like
he'll be like oh it doesn't matter your
age doesn't matter your weight like like
looks don't matter i'm like what the are
you nuts they're all that matters and
dating
eggs and
being in a cr you know empowering
yourself for most of your life and
essentially you're the product of the of
the
you know the the
the
your product of the choices that you've
made for as long as you've been around
but don't worry about it i'll make sure
these guys sort of make up for the the
bad decisions and and sort of absolve
you the responsibilities of those things
if that's not what
fresh and fit or or if that's not what
the man is sort of leaning towards right
now like female accountability i don't
know what is
and so that's number one and then number
two is this is
what hafiz does not
wrap his head around
is that we live in a gynocentric social
order that's why that's the biggest
difference between those two comparisons
right there
because for men when you go and you look
at what is it i just saw the uh the
research data on this which was uh
30
or was it 30 of men are not having sex
at all under the age of 30 or something
like that i forget what the stats are it
just came out and then you have women
who aren't having children at least in
the uk and i think probably the u.s as
well who are it's at the lowest
fertility rate for women uh past age 30
right now
so it's and no other time in history
have women at 30 years old been
single and childless
since they started keeping records
so
if if we
if we're so
we're so concerned about when the plight
of women
that we are looking at men and saying
you need a man up so that you can
fulfill the destiny of women and their
life plans and so they don't have to be
30 years old and single and childless if
we're doing that
instead of looking at those guys and
saying you need to man up and take
responsibility with no authority you
need to start looking at the issues and
the reasons behind that
you need to dig deeper you need to
distill it down to what are the core
reasons why men are the way they are and
women are the way they are right now and
you do yourself no favor as hypergamy
as long as
and certainly not the guys you are
pretending to help right now
by keeping and couching everything in
this emotionalist well you need to deal
with his inner pain blah blah blah oprah
winfrey dr phil crap it was just it was
it was really interesting and and it's
and it's really upsetting to be honest
with you yeah it's really sad yeah
people are better with somebody else i
think it's hard to be alone like life is
tricky life is hard um it is sad that's
interesting that you could see people
open up like wow
anybody remember uh how much uh oh yeah
honorable rolos i'm gonna guess i
haven't seen rolo's take on this but she
said i had to be okay with being alone a
crow i have to eat and how much uh crap
how how far i get run up the flagpole
thanks for that one
when i say men and women are better
together than they are apart how many
times have you heard me say that
i've been saying that for as long i i
remember when i said that for the first
time on uh on the pat campbell show
and people were like oh yeah rollo's
actually he's now he's on our side no
i'm just making up i'm making objective
you know
observation here first of all
women of course are women and men are
obviously better together like the test
society function i think that we are
innate natural
compliment our men make up for women's
weaknesses and women make up for men's
weaknesses and we're better together
than we are apart but you won't hear
them repeat that
women and men are better together than
apart do their research enough i guess
to have gone and figured out that quote
which by the way is it it's in at least
two of my books
uh it's in um
uh book four the religion book excuse me
and um and positive masculinity as well
i guess they weren't doing maybe that's
because they haven't been doing their
research
bad yeah and i think uh i think to me
it's just like
when you when
with guys in that that far red pill
space when you tell them they're you
guys are hurt men yeah
it triggers them yeah because it makes
no it triggers if it trigger if it
triggers them it triggers them because
you are having
an emotionalist conversation with
emotionless goals yeah that's what when
i watched this earlier i just felt like
it was so like it accomplished nothing
the conversation
like a real conversation would be was
that stuff true not oh
these men are so emotional da da da
and they are trying to have can you meet
me no you you're supposed to bring it to
my flat
oh my god hello
hi i'm in flat four
yeah just um click the buzz button and
then click fl four i'll buzz you in
say that again
uh well i i paid to get it delivered to
the door so um can you just buzz it
like it's so annoying
i'm like i hate it when the driver's
here i'm like i pay you
to
come to my door i'm streaming sir
an empirical
debate with you they're trying to say
here are the numbers hafiz here's what's
going on in the real [ __ ] world
how do you parse that out tell me
i i would like to know
how do you parse that data
out
with your belief set because you're
having this argument
with the goal of is this right is this
wrong does it feel good does it not feel
good
uh how is what's positive about that
where's the positivity where's the love
in all of this right that's the goal and
i'm not saying that that's not even
necessarily a bad goal but when we're
talking past each other it's because my
goal is to
show you the data and show you the
empirical material
observable
facts here and say well what do you
think is this true or is this not true
it doesn't matter because you're not
focused on whether it's true or it's not
you're focused on whether it feels good
or it doesn't or i'm a bad person or i'm
a good person that's the that's what
you're trying to
that's the end state of whatever your
debate is all about i made this or i
read this on last sunday's show but
again it's all in emotions they they
presume
that our that all every human being's
priority
should be based on this
emotional
are you hurt are you not hurt uh you
need to deal with the hurt first and
then come back to me no you need to deal
with the data and then come back to me
that's what you need to do
makes them feel like you're emasculating
them
but i think we don't understand like
what hurt means
to be hurt is to be human
and a lot of times when you have a
visceral attitude towards somebody it
usually comes when you really value and
love a person so i always say that's why
some of your arguments with your
siblings are some of the most
contentious or a spouse intentions
because the more you feel the more
you're going to understand these drivers
here like oh my god they irritate me
because this is what they'll do
this is what they'll do they'll
oh my god i paid to get it
hello
four flat four um are you did you go to
the house next to the co-op
oh yeah okay i got you
okay see you soon it's um you can go to
the first floor
okay
like it's just when i pay for something
like otherwise
if i wanted to go out in the cold i
would have
got up sorry
they always do that here
never in the u.s
respectfully
can idolize someone the more you could
potentially demonize individuals as well
so if a lot of these guys it's like
they put so much into women and into all
women so i want to say women into all
women and when that woman hurts him in
any way shape whether it's you know
something as simple as she just didn't
want him because she wasn't interested
to where she heard him or cheated on him
now
that creates this anger and hurt
animosity towards everybody to where now
you go online
okay how many emotions did hafiz
just
describe how how many emotions did he
just use
love
hurt animosity uh what else i mean you
could just run down like
rewind i know and they never even talked
about numbers once
okay here hold on guys
okay thank you
thank you
oh god
okay
bro i've been here for so many hours
you guys should
if you've been here for more than like a
half hour please send a donation like
don't don't we got beef if you
like don't there's a couple of you
that have called into my show multiple
times that watch me all the time and you
have never sent a donation
like
just a bit rude bit rude
um she's making angry promo no i look at
if i pay you to bring it to my door then
i pay you to bring it to my door
oh my gosh
find that part right how many different
emotions did he just describe in
presuming
that that's the right that's the goal
state
that's where we ought to be
these guys are angry they're angry at
what they're angry at women no they're
angry at themselves if anything and why
are they why would they be angry at
themselves because now they have this
data
and they understand that the life that
they thank you for the donation i very
much appreciate it thank you sir
they have built for themselves up to
that i don't know what dkk is i have no
idea what the conversion rate is but i
was at 170 dollars
before towards the 1 000 goal because i
want to get four more mics and a sound
board point was based on bad data was
based on a rule set and an old order way
of thinking that nobody was really using
although they thought it was and it felt
good to think it was their idealistic
way of approaching love and life and
everything else was going to everybody
else was going to do we're all playing
on the same rule set no no we find out
that we're not
now we find out what the data sets are
now we find out that women want you know
a guy who's economically attractive we
find out that he they want the guy who's
got the six pack abs is six feet tall
six-figure income
two dollars is better than no dollars
okay i don't care what the donation is
i'm just saying if you've been watching
my content for a minute
support the channel it's like two bucks
i won't kill you you know um
whatever
we can look at the the impact thank you
thank you thank you thank you very much
i appreciate it we're at like 180 182
ish in terms of donations miracle data
set after data set after data set
if they're angry or they're frustrated
or if the emotional response is
is to anything
it's to that
it's to the belief that this that oh my
god i've wasted part of my life
i mean hopefully you find out about the
red pill guys i hope you find out about
the red hill
in your 20s
yeah hopefully you find out about your
teens right but i think you kind of have
to have this sort of lived experience
before you can really appreciate it but
let's just say for sake of argument you
have to have been hurt at some point and
found the red pill like something has
had to happen i don't think you make it
to 25 without being hurt at some point
from a relationship unless you're
married to your high school sweetheart
or something you find the red pill at 25
you're in a you're in pretty good shape
but you're still probably pretty pissed
because you have most likely made
decisions where you've had experiences
or maybe you had that painful lesson
that you learned because you didn't
understand the game you didn't
understand that the women that you were
trying to get with or the women that
might have hurt you according to hafiz
the reason why you got hurt is because
you have bad data bad data from guys
just like hafiz that's why oh man oh man
he's taking shots
shot that idealistic pollyanna you know
deer in the headlights look you know
glazed over saccharine smile
and then you've got
michaela peterson over here bro
i'm sorry i'm starving i've been doing
this for like three hours i'm gonna get
a cup of water
but i want to finish this okay
i'll be back hold on hold on